hello everyone and welcome to
the 2020 version of the wolfram
technology conference
i am pleased and honored to introduce
stephen wolfram hi there
okay well welcome to the
31st year of our annual technology
conference
and first time it's been virtual it's a
shame to um
not be able to see people in person but
it's good that
uh a bunch of additional people are able
to attend because it is virtual
so it's been um about
uh it's been a little over 32 years now
since we launched mathematica
and uh it's hard to believe but i think
we have
even more to discuss today than we ever
have done any previous year
um it's kind of like after 32 years
haven't we finished everything yet
uh no actually the more we build the
further we can see the further we can go
the faster we can go
uh there are a lot of long-term projects
that we've been working on some of which
are just now coming to fruition
and i'll be excited to tell you about
some of those things and there are some
projects that are shorter term
that have been started even in the past
year or so that are coming to fruition
that i'll also be able to tell you about
so i'm going to talk about some several
different kinds of things here
um yes i'm going to show you lots of new
technology that's coming
particularly in version 12.2
which should come out in the next month
or so
but i also want to talk about kind of
the big picture of what we're doing
and what we're trying to do and about
the very important role that uh you and
our community
can and should play and what we're what
we're trying to do
well this time last year
we had uh just released version
uh 12.0 let me arrange myself
here oops
and i want to
okay we had just released version
12.2 2.0 um
and uh let me make that bigger um
and um we released this actually in
april of last year
we were about halfway through the 12.1
development cycle 12.1 was released
in um uh march 18th of this year
um and actually last year last october
it took me four hours to go through the
features that were upcoming in 12.1
um so i'm going to try and go much
faster here today
um let me mention the highlights of 12.1
because what came out in the final 12.1
was a bit bigger
than what was in the uh the preview that
i showed you
so um uh there were
a total of um um
182 new functions in that point one
release which is a pretty remarkable
thing that a point one release
um ends up with 182 new functions um
this is uh just a
a list of those those new functions um
the uh so i wrote about this um
at length as i want to do here
um and you can you can find all sorts of
different things
about the different uh features of 12.1
that i wrote about back in in march of
this year so
it was a very um uh very impressive
collection new functionality
a big effort to get it out right in the
middle of an emerging pandemic
um just to make things even more
exciting
but after 12.1 came out
in march of this year we decided to do
something we hadn't done before
which is to have a release that was a
pure
uh polishing release so three months
later we brought out version 12.1.1
june 17th and the main thing about
12.1.1
was that it had a thousand bugs fixed in
it
um the oldest one was documentation bug
actually from 1993
uh the oldest code bug was from the year
2000. and here's a here's an image that
i made as a
oh gosh these are all coming out too
small um
here's an image that i made as a kind of
a a tweet image to illustrate
our uh various bugs of different
severities that got fixed in that
release
okay so what happened in the three
months
since june um i should explain that we
always have a big pipeline of new stuff
coming
there's some projects that have been
running for years um others that
uh that are quite new um and if you've
been watching our live streams
uh you will have seen a lot of this
sausage being made you will have a lot
seen a lot of the designs for the things
that are coming in version 12.2
uh being developed and beyond to our
point to actually
we've so far done about 400 of these
live stream design review meetings
um it's uh we founded a very
productive way to work not least because
we have
a terrific group of people who tune into
these live streams and give us
suggestions and real-time feedback and
that's been really helpful
and in version 12.2 you'll see a bunch
of things that was suggested by
people on our live streams actually uh
come to fruition
and be released as a as a piece of the
product so we're
we're very happy about that well okay
let me give you kind of a um um
a bit of a summary of of what's coming
in 12.2
uh there are at current count a bit over
a hundred new functions
all finished in the past six months um
it's kind of an interesting uh
a set of data points um in the one year
between
version 12.0 which had 278 new functions
and version 12.1 there were 182 new
functions accumulated
in the six months since version 12.1
we've accumulated about 100 new
functions that will go into 12.2
so a sign of what feels to me like it's
acceleration and that's what we see in
terms of
the count of number of functions just to
recap
of some of the things that were new in
12.1 things like the data structure
functionality that came out of our
compiler project
uh asymptotics as a way of doing a new
level of symbolic analysis
things to do with data set and its
formatting and table view
things like cross hatching of graphics a
kind of whole calculus of annotations
approach
to dealing with annotations in in graphs
and images and all sorts of other things
uh things in sort of functional
programming and symbolic programming
like splice
and operator applied and so on a lot of
stuff to do with
geocomputation meets geometry being able
to treat geographic
uh things using our geometrical
computation uh
capabilities things like external
identifier and wiki data data
as ways to reference uh canonical
external
uh kinds of entities uh
things about molecular structure ocr we
in 12.0 you might know
that we introduced a lot of capabilities
around uh molecular and chemical
computation
uh also in 12.1 external storage
capabilities
and also sort of first classing our
paclet system
for releasing for the distributing kind
of additional functionality for the
system
okay so what's there in 12.2
so what i'm going to do i'll consider
this a bit of a spoiler for what's
coming later
but i want to give you some some
indication of some things then i'll
talk about a bunch of other other kinds
of topics
um so in 12.1 we started on video
uh putting video as a first-class kind
of thing in world language
um there's a lot more of that in 12.2
although it's and it's very strong there
although still not finished there in
geocomputation we've got things like
vector maps we've got a big effort
in spatial statistics we've got more in
synthetic geometry
uh drawing euclid figures drawing
molecules
we've got a new effort in biosequences
for dna and proteins
and making all of that computable we got
a bunch more hardcore math
of things like function properties more
asymptotics a bunch of new algorithms
we've invented
more on convex optimization we've got a
big new pde
partial differential equation modelling
framework um
also things of machine learning ability
to make custom layers and finer control
of
of the kinds of things that we can do
and compilation and so on
um also actually deployment to external
devices and such like
we've got another big area is remote
batch cloud
jobs and also some some cool and perhaps
unexpected user interface capabilities
that's kind of the the coming
attractions of version 12.2
all right i want to talk about that um
uh in in much more detail later
but first let's talk about some other
things well
um of course there's been a pandemic and
we've been kind of um
uh trying to do our part let me see
what's this
no that's not what i wanted okay we've
been trying to kind of do our part
uh to support the world in this um
unusual
uh uh event and um
uh since we're a data company from the
very beginning we were
curating and deploying in computable
form on the web
data about the pandemic we've been doing
that every day since the pandemic
uh started and i think people have been
finding that
very useful we have a variety of
different kinds of kinds of data
we've also been doing um
lots of computational essays by people
in our community
and ourselves about what's going
what's uh what one can do with that data
um and
and uh a variety of other things here
that are directly kind of
um uh providing sort of computable
support
for pandemic um related uh analysis
so uh i must say i i started off from
uh really trying to study the
epidemiology of the pandemic and the
decided that it's a lot harder than one
thinks and there's a lot of data one
doesn't have
a lot of conclusions one can't make and
much that i think is still mysterious
about what's going on but
let's not talk about the science of that
here right now
but another very practical thing that we
did was simply
uh providing um uh resources for
universities and so on um to uh
make um to make our products more
readily available
in these kind of virtual times that's
been
particularly leveraging our cloud
technology and in terms of providing
access to mathematical online and that's
been a very
successful program another thing that
we've been doing um
just recently for this school year is
providing some home-schooled courses
which are just about to start up
uh for students who are um not able to
be
um in the schools they would usually be
in um we also
uh another uh quite different kind of
thing
people can't do lab experiments as
readily um
in uh in these times and our system
modeler product line
has um uh had found lots of use
in being able to do virtual experiments
um
that can be done uh uh without being
being physically there
so there's also the
at the research level of um studying the
pandemic
um lots of use of our
um technology and i'm looking for there
we go
um and uh
here's some here's actually a word cloud
of
of uh papers this year that have cited
our technology and you'll see um all
kinds of different topics covered here
and there's a
there's a cluster somewhere here for
epidemiology
and covert and so on i'm not sure i can
find that cluster and all of the other
a there's a covet 19 cluster and
there'll be other ones here for
uh for various kinds of um epidemiology
and so on but it's been nice to see our
technology used
um not only for epidemiology but also
for things like fluid flow studies and
so on
related to uh to the pandemic
um you know in all the bad things that
happened with this pandemic there are
also
some things that um uh it's nice got
pushed to happen
uh i've been doing myself a number of
kind of public service kinds of things
one thing i started
uh pretty early in the pandemic um was a
um a weekly kind of um uh science and
technology q a
for for kids and others which we've been
live streaming and
um uh i've at least been having a lot of
fun with it
um we can we've uh have a bunch of sort
of podcast episodes here from it
um and i think it's um it's helped make
me a bit of a better explainer
of all kinds of things and all kinds of
strange questions that come in
so that's been something that uh that
has been a productive thing that that's
come out of this
of course this is a good time to have a
a geo-distributed company we have such
such nice offices in places like
illinois and the uk and so on
it's a shame that they have been so
abandoned but
uh we have been a geo-distributed
company for uh for 30 years now
um and that's been something which uh uh
has meant that we've been able to
continue to be productive through these
times
um i myself have been a a remote ceo now
for
29 years and people used to say what a
crazy thing to do
um uh but uh in these times doesn't look
quite so crazy and they were like you
were ready for this
all along okay well so nobody expected
this pandemic
and um but uh another thing that was
very unexpected
for uh for me personally that happened
in this past year
um for um uh
um uh the um
um uh
was um the um uh was
the our physics project um another very
that was another very
surprising thing in in my life so to
speak
um and uh as as uh
some of you may may know um
well a year ago at a technology
conference last year
um i i said i was going to work on this
and um indeed i did and it turned out
better than i could ever possibly have
imagined
um it's uh exciting both for the physics
of what it's brought
and for a bunch of applications um that
it's provided and also
for a bunch of metal lessons that i have
learnt from the very doing of this
project
and the fact that it was possible to do
it well so
by way of backstory as as uh many of you
may know
i used to do physics when i was a kid
and i but i've been so
out of the business professionally for
about 40 years now
and uh for those uh who may be here who
knew me back in the day
uh uh yes i'm i'm sort of back again now
um i mean i've been in those intervening
years i've been sort of alternating
between uh basic science and technology
about five cycles i think so far um
but uh back back in the day 40 years ago
i was very interested in fundamental
physics and worked a bunch on that
and then kind of got involved in what i
saw as being something in a sense
more fundamental than that in going
beyond the kind of
uh the sort of mathematical models and
so on that we've developed and
had been developed in in fundamental
physics and trying to see what are the
sort of most fundamental models that we
can make of things
and so on and that um uh led me
into studying uh computation
and programs and so on as sort of a a
more fundamental substrate
for the ways that one can build up
models of things and and sort of from
that effort
spun off uh the things that um
uh in complex systems research and so on
even if that particular field
didn't work out entirely as i might have
might have liked it to
it was a nice thing to kind of spin off
from those early studies
but um the real sort of question uh that
that i was interested in at that time
was
okay if we're going to take um uh
programs and computation
as sort of the foundation for how uh
things work
what does the typical program actually
do
and um for those who who are not um
aware of this let me let me just uh
bring up a few a few kinds of things
here
so if i uh what i got interested in were
some sort of very simplest possible
kinds of programs so this is a
cellular automaton just a line of black
and white cells and here's a rule that
says what the next color of a cell will
be
after it has a particular arrangement of
cells on the previous step
so if we if we run that um uh that rule
for for a few steps we'll get um
this kind of pattern here we're just
starting off with one black cell at the
top there
and it's very simple rule and we get
very simple behavior
do the same thing here and um we
can run that again and uh again
we'll get very simple behavior so the
question that i
first sort of asked um about
in the in the early 1980s was okay
so these simple programs produce very
simple behavior but is that true of all
simple programs
if i just look at all possible simple
programs of this type for example
uh what kind of behavior will they all
produce and so
these days it's very easy to do that
computer experiment um
here's here's the result and we see that
each one of these pictures corresponds
to a different program a different rule
and we see that many of them produce
very simple behavior maybe some of them
produce these nested fractal patterns
and so on
but um kind of pointing this sort of
telescope into this computational
universe of possible programs
the most remarkable thing that i saw
back in 1984
or so um there's actually i saw it
earlier than that but i didn't realize
what i'd seen until about 1984
was this thing that i call rule 30.
and if we uh if we go here
go down here and let's let's just um
look at rule 30 here's
here's the rule that it has and let's
just
um run that rule let's say we run it um
for 400 steps here just starting off
from that one black cell at the top
and i should have typed 30 there um
then um this is the behavior we get
and oops what did i just do
the um so
single black cell at the top very simple
rule yet the behavior we get
um is far from simple in fact for
example if we look at the
the center column of cells down here for
all practical purposes it seems
completely random
so this is really for me was a very
remarkable thing a very kind of
intuition breaking
kind of discovery kind of my all-time
favorite science discovery
that in this computational universe of
possible programs
even a program as simple as this can
sort of effortlessly produce
great complexity in its behavior and i
think that's sort of a
a a fundamental result and a fundamental
fact
about the way the computational universe
and abstract programs work
and it's something that over the years
since that time i've
done a lot to try to understand the
consequences of that kind of uh
of that scientific discovery
and over time that sort of gave me
a whole new way to think about all sorts
of kinds of science in fact
um eventually it led to this big book
that i wrote called the new kind of
science which tried to apply
that kind of what um what i discovered
from sort of
exploring the computational universe of
possible programs
to all sorts of different kinds of
systems in nature and to modeling all
sorts of kinds of things from biological
growth
to fluid flow to lots of other kinds of
things like that
and by the way it's been a really nice
thing to see because historically
uh they've been about for about 300
years there was kind of this dominant
idea that if you wanted to make models
of things
mathematical equations were the place to
go and i would say in the last probably
20 years or so
there's been a real transition towards
when a new model is going to be made of
something
the vast likelihood is that it will be a
model made in terms of programs not in
terms of equations
and that's a that's a big deal that
after 300 years
we've managed to get in in only 20 years
a real transition to new models being
made primarily in terms of programs
um and that's for me an exciting thing
um it's also by the way
when we look at the sort of
computational universe of possible
programs
it's also a great place to mine
technology from to find
these programs that do interesting and
useful things and just like we find
interesting useful materials
in the physical world we can kind of
mine these programs
to use them as algorithms for things
that we try to to to
do but in uh when i wrote new kind of
science
one of the use cases for the kind of
methodology that i was developing
um of exploring the computational
universe and simple programs in it
one of the use cases was can this be
applied to fundamental physics
to a theory of our whole physical
universe and i wrote about 100 pages
about that
in in the nks book and i figured out
quite a bit about how that might work
and i was pretty pleased with some of
the results i got
um and uh but i didn't i didn't uh
i i only viewed it as kind of a use case
for my main methodology
and didn't really take it as far as i
could have done at that time
unfortunately even though the in a sense
the market
found the idea of modeling with simple
programs really interesting
for many areas of science and technology
and engineering and
and so on in fundamental physics there
was very much of a we've been doing
mathematical equations now for a few
hundred years
they're working just fine for us thank
you very much we don't need anything new
and uh so the result of that was that i
basically didn't end up
working on um uh on developing the
fundamental physics directions of uh new
kind of science
um instead i worked on little things
like wolfram alpha
and then welcome language and so on and
um building our whole sort of
computational language
uh vision um and so i was i was very
happy to do that
but then about uh a year and a half ago
um i well a couple years ago i made a
little bit of a minor methodological
breakthrough
and thinking about sort of fundamental
physics and a couple of um young
physicists
uh told me you know you just can't leave
this stuff undone
you just have to go and push forward and
uh
and try and see whether it really works
to think about fundamental physics and
in these kinds of terms and so we did um
and uh it's worked out just great
well i i thought it would be a lot
harder than it actually turned out to be
i mean i thought that um we would sort
of see
we might be able to get to the first
kind of 10 to the minus 100 seconds
in the evolution of the universe and
then we'd be fighting with this
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility
we kind of can't foresee what the
consequences of our computation will be
much faster than just running them we'd
be fighting with computational
instability
and we wouldn't be able to see uh much
past that
um but the um uh the big surprise is
that
in fact we have been able to go a lot
further than that
um in fact uh we've been able to see
that
from this from these very simple
underlying ideas and very simple
underlying framework
we're able to reproduce uh for example
the two great pillars of 20th century
physics
general relativity and quantum field
theory and that's that's a really
exciting thing
and uh what we found is that from a
model that is just outrageously simple
we're able to go and kind of uh
progressively check off
more and more aspects of what we know in
physics
um and it's it's going just
spectacularly well i mean let me
i'll just give a very rough walkthrough
of of what's
uh uh what's what goes on here and i'm
going to talk about this some more on
thursday evening for people who are
interested
basically one of the key ideas is to
think
sort of underneath space and time what
are they made of so to speak and usually
when we think about space for example
you don't think what it's made of
we just think it's some manifold and we
can place a point wherever we want
that's been kind of the idea last couple
of thousand years um
the the idea that we start from is
something sort of more computational
imagine that there are just atoms of
space just points
and uh imagine that we have this kind of
structure
that um represents space that is just a
bunch of these points and all we know
is how these points are joined to each
other they're joined like a in a network
or in fact in in general in a hyper
graph and so then what we say is that's
sort of the structure of space
now the way that this that time uh
works is that at every moment we're
looking around in this hyper graph and
we're saying there's some simple rule
that we might use that can rewrite a
piece of the hypergraph to some other
form
and we just apply that over and over
again and just like in the case of
something like rule 30
we can go from a very simple initial
condition very simple rule and we build
up these very complicated structures
these structures uh end up on a very
large scale having properties
that can be very much like the space
that we're used to seeing it's kind of
like what happens in fluid dynamics
when you start off from that sort of
microscopic molecular dynamics of a
bunch of molecules
bouncing around and then a large scale
you see considerate continuum fluid
mechanics
in our case instead of getting continuum
fluid mechanics from these atoms of
space kind of
um interacting what we get is
einstein's equations for the structure
of space-time
so that's that's already quite exciting
one another thing that happens is
that as we look at kind of this
rewriting of hypergraphs
in terms of these simple rules one of
the things that's sort of inevitable is
that there are many possible ways that
that rewriting could happen
and that means that instead of thinking
about a sort of single history for the
universe we're thinking about this whole
kind of multi-way graph of possible
histories for the universe
and it then turns out that this
multi-way system um
actually reproduces the things we expect
in quantum mechanics
and in fact right now we're we're the
the
uh sort of close to having some kind of
formal proof
of the exact equivalence of of our
multi-way systems
to things like um categorical quantum
mechanics and so on which kind of nails
the
uh nails the case shut so to speak in
terms of the equivalence of our models
um in that case with quantum mechanics
we can already see many kinds of things
that um
uh that correspond and we can uh um and
so on
one of the things that's really nice is
for example we end up in this kind of
multi-way
uh graph we end up having something
which is kind of the equivalent
when we kind of slice space time in
time slices we get space when we slice
the multi-way graph
in time slices we get something that
isn't space but it's a bit like space
it's a thing we call branchial space
it's a space of branches uh it's a sort
of a map of quantum entanglements
between different quantum states
and one of the things that i think is is
really cool is that
the uh the kind of the behavior of pods
behavior of gd6
in physical space and the einstein
equations that govern how physical space
work
um what the precise analog of those
equations in branchial space
is none other than the feynman path
integral for quantum field theory
so in a sense if one was wondering for
these two pillars of
of 20th century physics um which have
had a hard time sort of being knitted
together
um what we've discovered is that
actually in some sense they are the same
theory
except one operates in physical space
the other operates in branchial space
so a lot of things that um
a lot of things coming out of this a lot
of really really interesting physics and
mathematics one of the things that's
been
been particularly interesting to me is
that a lot of approaches
to um uh to mathematical physics of the
more abstract particularly the more
abstract ones
uh they seem to all be kind of connected
to our approach to physics
it's almost as if we have this kind of
rosetta stone for all of these kinds of
very abstract
mathematical physics a little bit like
what happened back in the 1930s when
turing machines were invented
there'd been these other approaches like
combinators and lambda calculus and
general recursive functions and so on to
the idea of computation
but once one had sort of the
concreteness of turing machines one
could kind of see how all these pieces
fit together
and i think that's what's happening with
with our model of physics
um and kind of uh approaches to the to
mathematical physics
well it's um there is one
kind of amazing if embarrassing point
about this whole uh
model of physics you can say what's the
sort of fundamental data structure of
the
of the universe according to this model
of physics
well ultimately it's basically a
symbolic expression
um and that's sort of embarrassing
because i've been thinking about
symbolic expressions for 40 years now
and they're the foundation for wolfram
language they're the foundation of
of snp the precursor to that um
and there's something i've been thinking
about for a very long time and for
various reasons
i never really imagined that uh
that one could be thinking about a a
symbolic expression with 10 to the 400
elements
that would represent our universe i was
always hung up on the idea
that symbolic expressions should be
built to mean something rather than be
purely structural kinds of things but
now what we realize is that that
same idea and many of the issues that
come up there
um are the things that we can use to
build kind of this fundamental data
structure
for physics well and it turns out just
as cellular automata
a sort of minimal idealizations of
parallel computation
so these new models that we have are
kind of minimal idealizations
of computation where it's where things
happen
without space without time
asynchronously and with arbitrary kind
of
connectivity and structure and so it
turns out
that not only are these things
interesting models for physics they're
also interesting models for lots of
other kinds of things
um and then many other applications that
are emerging uh one of the ones that
i've been looking at quite a lot
is a bulk theory of meta mathematics a
kind of theory
of how mathematics grows and how the
network of all possible theorems of
mathematics
is laid out in kind of meta-mathematical
space
um there's also uh the possibility for a
new kind of approach to
uh theories of biological evolution um
there's also
a um a new approach to thinking about
distributed blockchain
that's coming out of this and in general
one of the things that's sort of
really remarkable is that a lot of the
issues about physics
have direct analogues and distributed
computing things like the uncertainty
principle in physics
direct analog in in um in the way that
things work
in the non-commuting of operations in
distributed computing and so on
and a lot that can be learned from 20th
century physics for example
that can now be applied to distributed
computing and vice versa
well another thing to say is that this
project of ours
um really wouldn't have been even
conceivably possible
um without uh uh without wolverine
language
i mean that that's what that's what
basically made this project possible
um and uh we've uh uh
we're making all the code uh for the
project uh directly available there it
is it's a
that's a those are all function
repository functions
um that you can use to run um
all these different aspects of our
models um
it's uh we've also been we've been
treating this as a very
open uh science project we've been kind
of doing the science both the
both the science itself and the way
we've been doing the science is i think
a different and sort of take on what's
possible so we've been uh
live streaming um uh everything we've
been doing and building
hundreds and hundreds of hours of um uh
of live streamed archives in fact i'll
show you one thing here let's see
yeah this is kind of cool this is
actually makes use of our
uh our new um video capabilities all of
these live stream
uh archives were processed with the new
video capabilities
in um in wolfram language um
we're also making available all of the
notebooks that have contributed
to this project going all the way back
to 1994
um and it's really cool for me to be
able to take a notebook that i produced
in 1994
and just start it up and run it um i
mean that to me is a
is a great sign of longevity and
stability of our language
um that uh that that's possible
and um well okay so
so there's lots going on with our
physics project there's a whole group
that's uh forming around it
and we're doing all sorts of study
sessions for people who are interested
uh we collected the um uh the kind of
the
launch documents of um
uh for this project in a um
in a physical book here we go this is
the physical book there we go
actual physical book um it actually
looks really nice it's
it's uh these um these images um
produced with with wolfram language and
without graph capabilities and so on
um come out uh really nicely there but
in any case
it's um i view our physics project if
nothing else
as a fantastic use case for orphan
language and uh
a fantastic sort of endorsement of the
computational approach to everything
i mean it's kind of it's computation all
the way down and we can really see that
now
well but in a sense even the bigger
story than sort of how physics works
is this whole story about uh
computational language
and about describing the world
computationally at all levels
not just at the level of fundamental
physics and this is kind of a mission
that i've been on for the last 40 years
or so
to ask the question we have this now
this sort of paradigm of computation
what can we do with it and it's a
paradigm that eventually affects
everything in our way of thinking about
basically everything
so you know in a sense i have a certain
point of view now about kind of how the
the science of this and the philosophy
of this fits together
i mean on the one side we have the
computational universe with things like
rule 30
and all of the kinds of models that we
have of fundamental physics
where there's this kind of ocean of
computational possibility
all of these different systems even with
very simple rules that do all these very
very complicated things
that's that's sort of the power of
computation uh kind of the the
that we can see throughout this
computational universe that's kind of
thing number one
thing number two is what we humans think
about
the actual kinds of objects that we
discuss the things that we talk about in
our human languages and so on
that's sort of thing number two and i
think one of the big challenges
is to make a bridge between those two
things to find a way to sort of connect
the what we what we think about with the
sort of ocean of computational
possibilities that exists
and in a sense i've spent most of the
past 40 years trying to build such a
bridge
and that bridge is the computational
language that we've created with wolfram
language
it's a bridge that tries to connect
what's sort of computationally possible
with the things that we humans think
about and giving us a way to kind of
form our thoughts in such a way that
they can be connected to this kind of
computational capabilities in a sense
it's kind of um you know what what is
the idea of
of a computational language it's it's
it's not like a programming language a
programming language is something which
just sort of tells a computer step by
step what to do
the idea of a computational language and
and often languages
is the only example of such a thing um
is
it's a language which tries to describe
everything in the world computationally
it tries to describe whether the thing
you're describing as
as a piece of an algorithm something
abstract whether it's a physical thing
about a movie or a
or a location on the earth or whatever
else um all of these things we're trying
to describe them computationally
we're trying to have a way to uh to take
those
things and have a precise symbolic
computational representation of those
things
and to do that we have to build into our
language
a lot of knowledge about the actual
world and a lot of knowledge about
computation
and that's what we've been trying to do
for all these years in in
language and one of the things that we
get at the end of this
is a language that is not only something
that is
relevant for explaining something to
computers
it's also relevant as a way to focus
what we humans are thinking about
so as you kind of think in computational
language you're kind of
casting your thoughts into a definite
form that has
a kind of computational structure and
that's a that's a really important
thing to do in a sense there's a story
behind there's an old story
of doing this like 400 years ago uh
people
were when they thought about mathematics
they were still thinking in terms of
describing mathematical concepts
in ordinary natural language words but
then this idea got invented in
mathematical notation
and suddenly there was kind of a
streamlined way to describe what you
wanted to do in mathematics
and that um and that was um
that was something that really opened up
the capability of using mathematics
as a way to think about things and a way
to communicate about things
and what that led to the invention of
mathematical notation led
to the development of algebra and then
calculus
and basically led to the creation of
kind of the mathematical sciences
which have for for many hundreds for
several hundred years kind of dominated
the approach to doing science and later
engineering and and so on
well in a sense what we're trying to do
with our computational language
is to provide a notation for
representing things computationally
and that's something that then allows us
to kind of think in computational terms
to kind of make our thoughts concrete
and computational
um and then to build from that and just
as mathematics and mathematical notation
built the mathematical sciences
so we can expect that this kind of
computational language and the way of
representing our thoughts
computationally
can build kind of the computational x
for all fields x
actually not just sciences kind of for
any field
we can imagine and we can expect a
computational version of that field
and i view sort of computational
language as a critical piece
of making things making the notion of
computation
concrete enough that it can actually be
applied and built on
to create those kinds of approaches to
things
and well
it's um in order to kind of
make this computational language really
work as i say one has
to build a lot of knowledge and
essentially intelligence
uh about the world and about things into
the language we have to sort of create
this this repository of computational
intelligence
um that we can then apply in in
different purposes
well it's um
uh it's kind of the you know
i've kind of viewed the idea of the sort
of computational paradigm
and our kind of computational language
as a way to make that concrete
as kind of the future of thinking about
almost everything and um
it's um you know it's it's a practical
thing that's
that's actual software and technology
but um
but more than that it's sort of a big
stack of ideas which are very powerful
um with which people can do amazing
things as as many of you well know
so one of the questions that um uh that
i'm sort of interested in
is how do we really spread this in the
world at large
um we have um sort of tremendous
potential with the computational
paradigm and our computational language
to unlock new opportunities both in
terms of subject subject matter
and in terms of who has access to that
subject matter and those capabilities
and there's sort of a big vision of what
we can do with the kind of computational
paradigm and computational language
the question is how do we get there and
what i've kind of increasingly realized
is how hard it really is i mean there's
a big thing that i realized over the
past year from our physics project
um it's not one of these things that's
just going to happen and quickly
i mean our physics project i think if we
hadn't
had the good fortune to start doing it
in the past year
would probably not have happened for 50
years um
it's uh something you know i i talked
about it 20 years ago i told millions of
people about it
nothing happened for 20 years i think
that we could
we can absolutely expect that nothing
would have happened for 50 years
except for kind of a fortunate set of
circumstances
and um well if we look at kind of the
vision of computational language which
we've steadily been refining over the
years
um it's uh it's some aspects of that
uh we've kind of seen uh be be really
absorbed comparatively quickly but the
bigger picture
i think is still a long way from being
absorbed i mean it's
it's uh you know even something as
straightforward as notebooks took about
28 years before it was sort of uh
copied and absorbed and people people
said this is a
this is now a mainstream thing um it's
but there's a lot more and um uh to
understand i think one of the things
that's been sort of a
an unfortunate paradoxical thing is that
the further we go in developing this
kind of vision of computational language
the faster we can go and the further
away we get
from what we have readily been able to
get absorbed in the world at large
i mean it's it's worth realizing that
wolfram language has now existed
for nearly half the time the digital
computers have been around
and you know lots of lots of amazing
things have been done with it including
by many people here
um but there's uh there's an awful lot
more that some
sort of a a true absorption of
computational language is capable of
doing for the world
and i you know i kind of suspect that
sort of left to its own devices
we will see the sort of discovery of
notebooks type thing
happen for many of the other ideas we've
had maybe 50 years
maybe a hundred um and uh maybe more
um and it's it's always fun i mean i i
find a lot of fun
to kind of bring artifacts from the
future
in to achieve things today i mean i kind
of
almost see myself as specializing in
that and i encourage other people to do
it it's really a lot of fun
um but i think it's kind of a
responsibility to the world
um to uh to have people more generally
understand what's possible
and to move things forward uh at faster
than sort of inexorable pace at which
it's it will otherwise happen
i mean i think that um uh it's kind of
like how should one best
kind of uh move things forward taking an
idea like this
and making it practical well the first
thing is just build the technology and
build it as well as possible
and uh uh obviously i've i've tried to
build the best possible vehicle for
doing that
and um i'm pleased with what we've been
able to build with our company over the
past 34 years
i think we've managed to create a kind
of rather spectacular engine for
innovation i think we've become over
those years
more and more of an outlier in the
technology industry i mean you know
we're an independent private company
which many people see as having kind of
a simple-minded view of business
in which we kind of make things and sell
them at sort of modest consistent prices
to people who use them i mean we're we
don't we haven't followed the kind of
pretending to give everything away but
make money behind the scenes by some
other scheme or something
we've taken a very sort of old-fashioned
and simple-minded view of a business
which allows us to kind of align the
things that we are really
uh trying hard to do in terms of
innovation with the kinds of things that
um that i think our true customers
are interested in well having said that
uh we've been working very hard to sort
of make our technology as widely
um available and accessible as possible
whether it's making you know free wolf
now for website
the cloud basic free site free wolfram
engine for
developers free will from engine on
raspberry pi's you know having site
licenses at all sort of all major
universities
and increasingly being able to having
our technology available
um through other companies and other
products
not only intelligent assistance but also
productivity tools
and so on i'll talk a bit more about
that later but
um for me i i think it's fair to say
that our our company
is is mostly a mission only a business
by necessity
i mean we've tried to sort of optimize
everything for innovation
sort of the opposite of most technology
companies most technology companies
uh most of the employees are on the
commercial side and only a minority or
in r d where the exact opposite most of
our employees are in r
d um rather than on the commercial side
but you know in the end we kind of see
ourselves as creating
a seed a seed that for kind of a
community to grow with
to to help sort of introduce this whole
paradigm shift
that uh that sort of computational
language can provide
to the world at large i mean
we we are definitely trying to do our
part um
but we need help i don't think our
company is well optimized as i've said
to uh uh we're well optimized to create
things to innovate
um but we're not um uh um
we're not optimized to um uh
uh for um uh to
to to be kind of trying to scale up this
process
of of speeding up the hundred year sort
of uh
absorption of ideas so i think um
uh it's um uh you know i think that
um uh we we kind of really need our
community
to help take this these ideas forward
and i know many of you have done lots of
things
along these lines which is terrific but
i've i've sort of realized particularly
this year and particularly as a result
of our physics project
how much more there is to do and how
little will happen
if we don't really make efforts to get
things to happen
it's um it's it's really uh um
it's um it's something that um uh that
requires kind of more of an intellectual
movement
than just uh what a company like ours
and particularly a company that's really
optimized
for innovation uh can can muster
and we we're so
uh the question is in a sense how can
people help with this
well there are things to do at all
levels from the small to the large
um some of them people may not realize
are worth doing and maybe i'll mention a
few of them
so you know very basic thing if your
organization
has a site license for our language
make sure people actually get our
technology make sure people can actually
get our technology
and if there's a problem with that let
us know
and do things like share what you've
done
with computational language with your
co-workers with other people
with your organization and um
uh when you see people who should be
using
computational language tell them that
and help them do it and when you see
other software
that should be connecting to to wolfram
language for example
tell the people who make that all the
software that that kind of connection is
useful
and tell us as well and maybe something
can actually be made to happen
you know it's um
you know there's a there's a sort of big
category of small things
which is to make sure that people
actually know
that people are using our technology one
of the things that
is quite frustrating to see is
lots and lots of people use that
technology to do lots and lots of kinds
of things lots of people do wonderful
things with our computational language
and they say well that's nice but we you
know
we don't need to we're not going to show
that to anybody maybe they think their
code isn't really good enough
maybe they think something else but they
don't kind of show it to people
but it's really important as a way to
kind of spread these ideas
that people know that people are doing
things along these lines
for example it's like list dwarfing
language on your resume
you know it's it's a it's an unfortunate
thing that people think
oh i'm using a computational language
i'm using this thing maybe i'm using it
through mathematica
um you know i learned three lines of
java code so i'll list java on my resume
but i won't list both language on my
resume that's unfortunate it's
unfortunate for us it's unfortunate for
the future
it's unfortunate for the people and it's
a mistake and it would be nice if if
people understood that it was a good
thing
it's um it's also people use us all the
time to do research
um they often don't cite us
they should it's um maybe when
mathematica first came out 30 31 years
ago uh it wasn't so obvious what you
should do with kind of software and so
on it is obvious today
and uh people should when they use
our technology in their research papers
and so on they should cite us in fact
when i was working on the physics
project i decided i'm going to
figure out what's a good way to cite uh
our technology and so on and i realized
that that individual functions are
really a good thing to cite
um and that's a that's a good way of
explaining what you're doing
um particularly if you if you have a
piece of uh
of of computational language right there
um
showing what's going on i mean this kind
of show your code
is an important idea this goes along
with the kind of
you know back in the days when
mathematical notation was first coming
about
some people didn't show their
mathematical notation they wrote what
they were talking about
in latin nobody can understand it today
other people actually started using
mathematical notation
and that's something which is a
transportable idea
that other people can really understand
and this is a kind of show your code
um type uh type type um
uh encouragement and and just like with
mathematical notation
there's better produced coding as worse
produced code the better produced it is
the better it will communicate to other
humans
the computer might not care but the
humans will
but um so we're actually making it
easier to cite individual functions now
you'll find
on every function page in documentation
you'll find this
this uh this box showing uh
the standard kinds of citations that are
that exist
there and actually we're going to we're
going to do something
which we hope all people will find
useful which is if you cite us we'll
cite you
um and provide a a place for sightings
of um of wealth and language on the web
which hopefully will lead people
to find papers it turns out my one of my
observations
is when you find a paper that does cite
open language
it's usually one of the really good
papers in the particular field that it's
that it's about so i think that our
sightings uh
uh database might might help people to
find those good papers
so it's um
i mean it's always also disappointing to
see places out in the world where
where we know we have really good things
to to contribute
and where people just are like oh we
didn't know that existed
and um in a sense it's it's it's fun
when you show people
that gosh we have this thing look we
have this website look we have this
capability
and people are like oh that's really
cool but it's also like
but it would be really nice that people
knew about this in general
uh like for example why aren't we used
more in wikipedia
we have tons of material from you know
our 13 000
free demonstrations which uh produce
pictures and so on which we've set up
from a licensing point of view
so that they can be clipped out and put
in wikipedia
or all of those functions with all their
examples and all of the kind of online
things that you can do with wolf and
alpha
turns out we just discovered that
there's this one guy who's been
basically systematically taking down
things that people put up about uh um
about our uh resources on wikipedia
it's kind of unfortunate that with our
whole community
one guy can basically take down uh all
the stuff that we're putting up
um i mean that's the world of um that's
the wild west of um
of these things i suppose but it's
unfortunate and i think it's not a good
statement
about what we're seeing in terms of of
energy from our community
and it's something that um from the
point of view of what we're trying to do
in uh in creating uh sort of the the
seed of innovation
behind bringing sort of computational
language into the world
it's pretty unfortunate um if we don't
see uh
uh if if um uh to to not feel that we're
getting um
uh support in those ways
it's um
you know as i say i think it's it's
both an important responsibility in the
world
to kind of bring this paradigm that that
uh that we understand
to people but it's something that is
also as i say fun to do whether it's
in person explaining stuff to people
whether it's writing papers about how to
use computational language
whether it's organizing workshops at
professional conferences
whether it's starting a github project
um to uh
with with um with wolfram language code
and so on
um and it's um or whether it's by doing
uh bigger things like writing books and
so on i tried to provide a template
for how people could uh uh could easily
produce kind of awful language based
books and i think a few people have been
doing that but
it's many more could and should i think
it's not so much about writing a book
about
how to use wolfen language to do x it's
more about
how you can do x using computational
language
where the book is really about doing x
and
the computational language and wolverine
language and the whole sort of
computational language
presentation of things is really just a
piece of kind of the um
uh the the um um
a piece of kind of the exposition of
what one's doing
rather than the main focus of what one's
doing the main focus is
you're explaining some topic and you're
using computational language it's kind
of the future
of how to explain things you're using
that as the vehicle for part of your
explanation
and by the way i i uh you know at this
point
we're very keen that people use wolfram
language as the term
to describe what we're what we're
dealing with in our computational
language
rather than mathematica mathematica is a
great thing and if you're doing
mathematical kinds of things it's a fine
thing to use as a description
but the fact is that's been one of the
things that has been
part of the kind of story of oh i
thought your thing only did math
and as the years have gone by that's a
um
uh the the the kind of the concept of
computational language and the things
we've been trying to do
have i think expanded far beyond that
and it's important to be able to
communicate that
and to not have people uh immediately
think oh it's math
you know math was the last 400 years now
we've got
computational language that's the next
however long
let's make sure that we can distinguish
those things
you know it is funny because i've been
around long enough
fortunately or unfortunately that i've
been able to see how lots of ideas and
things have developed in the world
and there are certain things that are
just completely inexorable
it's it's it could not happen any other
way i mean this is what i
saw with kind of the way that the idea
of using simple programs
as foundations for models of things that
was inexorable
that that would have to be a thing that
happened um so it's also inexorable that
the whole idea of computational language
the whole ideas about computational
essays as ways to explain things
the whole idea of sort of a symbolic
representation of the world and so on
this is all completely inexorable there
is no question
this is this is the way things will
happen the whole ideas of symbolic
programming and so on
um however uh left to its own devices
without our community to push it forward
it might take a hundred years
um and uh uh but it is um it's some
um it's something that uh
um uh it's it's nice to know that one is
kind of on the right side of history
and that um and that these things will
inevitably eventually happen
the the fun is to be part of the of the
front lines of actually making them
happen because that's kind of the um
uh uh you know for the for most people
this is all sort of ideas from the
future um and it's
it's uh uh it's it's really it's kind of
it's always fun to bring those ideas in
to the to the world today
and it's also an opportunity for people
to kind of become leaders
in this sort of computational future um
it's something which
many people who are here today uh know
well
and it's something which is sort of a
tremendous personal and organizational
opportunity
for people and intellectual opportunity
for people to
to actually establish things in this in
this kind of frontier
that i think is sort of inexorably
moving in this direction
okay well i said i was going to show you
some new technology and i will get to
that
but first i want to talk about sort of
how to access our technology
so let me um go back to that
and
so there are many ways to kind of
access computational language welcome
language
um start off with the desktop there's
things like wolfram desktop which is um
uh uh like mathematica starts
as a as a desktop thing um
it's part of what we call wolfram one
which is the kind of the future of how
we intend to deliver things
it's a combined desktop and cloud
product that lets you access things and
use
things both directly on your single
desktop computer
and in the cloud um
and sort of the the the um
number one kind of access method um
in that mode of working in the world
from one
mathematical wolf and desktop or from
cloud uh
mode of working the number one sort of
method of access is through notebooks
one of the things that we've been
working very very hard on particularly
in the last year
is notebooks in the cloud giving one
kind of a no compromises way
to be able to deploy notebooks to the
cloud to be able to take
any desktop notebook whether it's 50
megabytes in size or whatever
and just say publish to cloud and have
that notebook be published on the cloud
so anybody anywhere can go and see that
notebook just like a web page except
it's not just like a web page
because it's got active components and
it has
sections you can open 3d pictures you
can move around manipulates you can move
all those kinds of things
right there in this sort of free
published notebook and um
you can also uh people can also say make
your own copy
and then they can go into cloud basic um
and they can freely make a copy of your
notebook in which they've edited things
and they can save it for up to 60 days
through cloud basic
i should also mention that um uh when it
comes to notebooks in the cloud another
thing that's been developing over the
last year
is our notebook embedder which allows
you to take a
a notebook and um uh
and um um embed it
in um um
uh in in a web page and so that's for
example in community
i think they're now a thousand notebooks
that have been posted that way
um that are embedded notebooks embedded
within community posts and so on
um but in general notebook embedder is a
good way to take
notebook content and just put it on any
website
you publish the notebook to the cloud
and then you just you use notebook and
better to bring the notebook onto
any website it's a more more flexible
way to do that than to use things like
iframes and so on
so um you can let me let me maybe show
you an example that
workflow uh let's see
okay what do we have here what is this
this is some giant notebook this is i
think a working notebook
from some um
uh physics session that we did
so let me take this notebook and just
show you what um uh
what's involved in publishing it to the
cloud so i just go to this menu item and
i say publish to cloud
and um it will go and eventually okay
let's say
automatically assign a url let's now say
publish that
okay i think this is a reasonably big
notebook so it might take a little while
um and that's it oops did i need to
enable dynamics though i don't know
the oh i probably needed to do that
because otherwise it can't format it
to be able to save it
there we go okay so now it's it's now
putting it in the cloud and there it is
it's now in the cloud there's a there's
that's kind of cute thing
you can um uh there's a qr code that's
useful if you're giving a lecture or
something
and you take the notebook that you've
used you say now i'm going to push it to
the cloud
and everybody can get out their phones
and just uh
um read in that qr code and be able to
immediately get that notebook
up um in the cloud on a on a in a web
browser on their phones
and they'll be able to browse that
notebook so now if we go
um if we go there let's go see that
notebook we can go and view it
in the cloud so now we'll be just going
to the cloud
and um this is now the published version
of that notebook and we can go down and
look through it
um and uh all these things are now
uh in our actual pieces of graphics that
we can do all kinds of things too if we
want to
um and now if we want to we can now say
uh create your own copy here i could say
download
and i could could could look at it um uh
using notebook player for example on a
desktop machine or i could say make your
own copy
and now it will make a copy in the cloud
oh boy
i didn't log in on this machine uh there
we go
okay there i am um
and this is uh oh interesting
um
let's see
the um no i don't need to remember it uh
okay so now that this will now be a copy
of that notebook
um that's been made for me and it has
everything everything now here is
editable
um so i can go and um i could probably
uh well actually this is a function that
was not is not globally defined so i
have to go and um
okay so it's now but now i can do any
computation i want with this i could go
here and i could just say you know
what's two plus two and it will now this
will now be an active notebook in which
i can do computations
so this is kind of the workflow that's
possible
now is to go from a desktop notebook
there we go um two uh if i waited a
little bit longer it would have
it would have the way this works is when
you push a notebook to the cloud
it is making an html cache of that
notebook
and when the notebook comes up the first
thing you see is the html cache
um and uh sometimes if you it's a little
bit shamanistic but sometimes if you
wait a bit longer
the html cache will have been created
and so the notebook will come up
instantly
if you ask to see it very impatiently it
will still be creating that html cache
it will still be it'll have to just
render from afresh
without having a cache when you first
bring it up um
but okay so so um uh but
but um there it is so this is uh this is
kind of the workflow of you create a
notebook you can create it in the cloud
you can create it on the desktop if i
have this one in the cloud i could say
here just publish
this and that will now go through the
same kind of dialogue
to publish this cloud-created notebook
uh as a
as a published notebook in the cloud and
and the rules are
anybody can see a published notebook in
the cloud unless you set it
to be something that has limited
permissions so in any case that that's
some uh
if you want to you can control access to
that notebook there's an elaborate
system for controlling permissions and
so on
but by default you publish a notebook
and it's visible to everybody in the
world
and runnable by everybody in the world
so that's kind of a
a um a bigger story when it comes to um
uh the um
uh what what you're dealing with here is
our public cloud the main world from
cloud
um we also make available uh private
versions of our cloud
enterprise private cloud product that
allows people to set up
their own uh notebooks serving private
clouds on their own infrastructure
or in in cloud providers infrastructure
um and um uh
so that's one of the things that
um uh that so all of the stuff that i'm
showing you about the desktop the cloud
you can interact not only with our
public cloud but also with private
clouds
which will have the same capabilities as
our public cloud
well so we're doing lots of different
kinds of things here but one of the
things that i thought i might show you
is um a uh um
a new kind of direction let me see if i
can bring this up here
a new direction um that is uh
using both desktop and cloud which is
a thing we call wolfram alpha notebook
edition which is kind of a
a combination of well from alpha and
wolfram language and wolf notebooks and
so the idea is
this is something initially and
primarily at education
where the concept is that you get to
give your input
as uh in pure natural language
so there's nothing there's nothing you
have to learn so i could just say here
integrate uh log
x times sine x or something
and um and this will now get interpreted
using
our uh um
using our natural language understanding
system what you'll get
is then a um a piece of of all
language code which you can then
evaluate or i could go on and i could
say something like
um uh what is the
uh density of tungsten
um and uh i should get a result there
that i can then compute with
and so what's interesting about this is
that you you both you can
immediately sort of walk up to it and
just like will from alpha you can start
working with it but then you can build
up progressive computations so
so back here if i go up here um i might
say let's try this again and let's just
just get
result again and now it would say
something like
um let's go and say let's look at um
related computations okay plot function
and integral okay let's do that um and
so
we get all of this uh we can it kind of
guides us through
being able to do different kinds of
computations but we can take
we can build things up in a way that is
not possible in will from alpha on its
own for example
we can build things up um just like we
could in mathematica or in wolfram
language
um so this is now available on on
desktops
um it is soon going to be available also
in the cloud
um so people can just go to their web
browsers anywhere
and start just like they can interact
with wolf and alpha they can interact
with wolfman for notebook edition
but now they're building up sort of full
computations that they can do things
with
and that they can turn into
presentations people can can uh
do all sorts of uh educational things
with this
um as i mentioned we we now have site
licenses at pretty much
every major university in the world um
one of the things we're doing to support
that
is to introduce single sign-on
capabilities for
our id system and that's just been
rolling out in the past few weeks a
bunch of universities
um uh have already uh already rather
rather rapidly got their systems hooked
up to our sso
capabilities and that's something that
um
we hope to get very broadly rolled out
over the next few months
um and uh something to encourage your
university to do is to get signed up
with the sso system
so that people can immediately use their
university
login credentials rather than wolfram
ids to get access
to to all of these things
uh talking of notebooks by the way it's
uh worth remembering our notebook player
on ios
um we've had now for a couple of years
the capability
of running a native wolfram language
kernel directly on an ios device like an
ipad or an iphone
um and uh that means that you can take a
notebook
and you can run it uh at sort of full
speed without ever having to interact
with the cloud
directly on that ios device i mean i use
this capability all the time because
people send me notebooks an email
and i can now just open them directly on
my phone
and interact with them there and that's
a very convenient thing
um and it's something where in
educational settings where people have
lots of ipads it's something very
convenient where you can just send
a bunch of demonstrations a bunch of
manipulates to the ipads and have them
have them run that way
okay
well notebooks are a great mechanism for
for doing things but sort of how else
can you interact with wolfram language
a big another big category is through
apis by having
programs call wolfram language on
servers and so on
so as you may know one of the things
we've had for many years now is instant
apis
where you can just take any piece of
wolfram language code you can just say
cloud deploy
an api function of that piece of code
and immediately you've got
this running web api that exists
that can run that wall from language
code from from anywhere
um and we've been we've been gradually
providing more and more capabilities
around that last year
we introduced um uh the uh
um client library for python so you can
just take
your you can basically treat all of
wolfram language as a giant library
uh you can kind of add computational
language to the python programming
language so to speak
by um uh by just using this client
library and by just
using wolfram language from from
directly from within python
and that's working by using api
both in the cloud and on the desktop
behind the api you can have either a
public cloud
either using our public cloud you can
use a private cloud
there's a new thing that's coming which
will be available which is already
available in beta test form
which is called wolfram application
server well from an application server
is a pure
api server for wolfram language
and it's something that allows it's
delivered in containers docker
containers kubernetes
uh things and it's it's um uh it's also
something that you can cluster
it's available both um uh as a as
something that you can run in your own
infrastructure
and something you can just get an aws or
azure uh container
um and uh a container in a virtual
machine there
to um uh to run the uh welcome
application server
and what it does is it just it allows
you to execute well from language apis
so it doesn't have all of the notebook
delivery capabilities it doesn't have
all of the authentication capabilities
um all of the kind of management
capabilities of
uh a private cloud but it just has the
ability
to serve apis um and that's something
where
if you're building a website you're
building kind of internal micro
services whatever it's a really
convenient way to deliver that
is to just have a welcome application
server put your code
you can you can directly uh uh
communicate with it from a desktop or
from language or a cloud welcome
language
you just say push this piece of code to
the application server now it becomes an
api
that everybody can access
we've also uh application server also
allows you to serve web
forms of the same kind that um that you
can serve throughout through our cloud
well there are many other interfaces um
the uh a big focus that we have these
days
is embedding our technology inside lots
of other kinds of systems in the world
and making it possible to um uh to have
um
to have our language um be something
that i
had various things i was gonna bring up
here but i didn't do it um
to have our language be something that
um um
one can um uh one can access
um as a as a piece of other systems that
one is using
and so for example uh it's sort of a
general piece of our strategy of sort of
delivering computational intelligence
everywhere and i guess my
my vision of these things is the
following that's sort of back in the
in the ancient past when they were first
computers when i was first using
computers
it was just a raw computer it didn't
have languages didn't have an operating
system
eventually one got to sort of take for
granted the idea that a computer would
come with an operating system
later that it would come with networking
capabilities or come with a user
interface
or whatever else it's kind of my my
vision that
um that in not too long when we'll be
able to sort of expect that
computational intelligence
the kind of thing we have in our
computational language will be something
that you can just sort of take for
granted when you walk up to a computer
and
we're seeing that happening through an
increasing number of kind of ways in
which our language and our
is getting integrated uh with systems
out in the world
so for example uh the list of things
that sort of our
computational language powers is it's
not too shabby already i mean things
like siri and alexa
use our computational knowledge uh we're
sort of the only provider of this kind
of computational knowledge in the world
um so it's sort of not not in a sense
too surprising but it's nice to see that
that um
uh um that that's a place where where
millions of people get access to
uh to what we built every day um another
major sort of uh piece of embedding
that's coming soon is
with microsoft um uh you'll see
um this is an example of uh of um
uh integration into excel um of being
able to take
um uh the kind of computational
knowledge that exists in wolf and alpha
um and be able to uh
immediately populate an excel
spreadsheet with it
and lots of other kinds of things uh
with wolfram language um
uh planned as well so
it's uh i mean this is this is kind of
the beginning of a strategy
with apple and amazon and microsoft
actually one other large partner to be
announced soon
um uh of using our computational
intelligence
um as a sort of unique source of
computational intelligence
um in a variety of uh of products that
are very widely used
and um so there's there's sort of a
question then
um if you're uh whenever you
sort of um uh
are using some some system out in the
world um could that system be kind of
supercharged
by adding computational intelligence
with our language and so on
and if so tell whoever makes it um
you know tell us bring us together we'd
like to see this happen
um i think that um uh you know whether
that's
a you know a specialized engineering
piece of software
that needs to make use of of uh our
capabilities
to know about real world kinds of things
to do natural language understanding
to analytics to do geometry whatever
else whether it's uh
some kind of educational system whether
it's some kind of piece of middleware
that needs that instant api
to uh to make it easy to do all kinds of
things
you know can it have wolfen language
embedded um and we now have the
technology
to embed in almost anything um and uh we
just have to
we just need kind of the bandwidth to
make the deals to make that happen
you know i should talk about kind of
non-cloud places where wolfman language
gets deployed
i mean there's hardware things like
raspberry pi where we're basically just
part of the operating system
um we also uh have our
um uh wolfram engine for developers
and uh we're trying to make sure that
this is available through sort of every
conceivable package manager
and that you can download it any way you
want um
this is intended to be uh free for
development
um and uh licensed for
deployment um uh when when one comes to
that point
and um so
we as i say we want to make our language
as ubiquitously available as possible
um so people can kind of take for
granted that they can get it
um we also want to make it so that
people can redistribute well from engine
easily
inside other products even open source
products we have a mechanism
for letting people distribute will from
engine as part of an open source project
and that's something that um uh uh just
to help uh this process of making sure
that the the things we built
and that this kind of paradigm we're
pushing is capable
of uh of being deployed as widely as
possible
we we basically don't ever want uh
something about the way that we license
products or that we have to license
things from
upstream providers of data and all those
kinds of things
to get in the way of letting people have
access to what we've done
i mean we've solved this problem at
universities and labs and so on
we will solve it for embedded wall from
engines
um we definitely haven't seen all
possible cases of embedded wall from
engines
because orphan engine has only been out
for a year or so
but we're committed to solving that in
all of these places
i might mention that one new thing
that's happening is there is a new
persistent wall from engine so normally
if you have a wall from engine you
launch it it just runs
it does its job it stops there's a new
thing called wstp server
which is a persistent wolfram engine
which kind of sits as a daemon-like
process on your computer
and can take can spawn all from engines
that that can do computations for you
and it can maintain a persistent wall
from engine
if if you want to so that you can
maintain state between different
computations and so on
so the uh i mean there are just many
many different ways
to uh deploy language uh if you look at
kind of the
the deployment options it's getting a
little bit um uh
it's a little quite a range i mean
there's at the server level
there's wolf and cloud which allows you
to deploy notebooks and apis and
scheduled tasks and all those kinds of
things
there's enterprise private cloud same
set of capabilities
there's application server which is for
deploying apis
there's the um uh this is a very
lightweight
um uh direct deployment
of a will from engine of the world
engine along with a web server
um there's uh yet uh even more
lightweight deployment with a web server
and so on and then there's wstp server
that i just mentioned
so these are all sort of for different
sizes and shapes of deployments
these are all ways to deploy wolfram
language um in
in in various kinds of systems
well it's all rather complicated and
it's it's complicated because the
world's complicated
and there are all kinds of different
places where one can potentially
insert a computational language and so
on one of the things we're working hard
on
is to sort of harmonize all these pieces
into what we call a hyper architecture
to sort of make it so all these
different components can be added
um as one as uh however one wants um
and uh sort of the goal is to depl
design our deployment space so that it's
really convenient design
sort of deployment the space of
deployments as we've designed the space
of functions in our language
and that's what this hyper architecture
concept is about
uh by the way another emerging kind of
deployment
is autonomous deployment of language
language in things like blockchains
so we have this operation called orphan
blockchain labs
uh which has been involved with
connecting uh wolfram language to lots
of kinds of blockchains
um it's also uh emerging as quite a
standard
uh for blockchain education uh it's very
convenient to study and use blockchains
from within wolfram language um it's
uh the biggest story though is the
emerging idea of computational contracts
where we're kind of writing
uh contracts directly in wolfram
language and we're using our source of
computational knowledge
to provide sort of facts from the world
for the operation of these contracts
um and so that's uh that's something
which is sort of a an emerging
um autonomous use of wolfram language as
something which just sort of
autonomously exists
in the in the blockchain world as a
piece of computational language
to be executed when a contract is
triggered so to speak
well there are there are just all sorts
of other deployments
i mean here's just a random example this
is a registry of notable universes
this is just a cloud deployment of of
wolfen language
there's a bunch of there's an embedded
cloud notebook there
um that uh um is about um
uh well this particular uh universe
model which i i doubt will be the one
but um uh it's it's it's one of them
uh here's another example this is a
project we've been doing for the uh
museum of math in manhattan um
this is a project to kind of uh collect
together
um lots of interesting um
artifacts from the history of
mathematics and two
i don't know which one to pick but um
i'll pick one of them
and to also provide okay that one was
coming soon
and to also provide computational essays
that kind of describe
the um uh um what uh what was going on
on let's say the rhine papyrus or
something um
there we go there's a there's kind of a
um and this is all just embedded
notebooks
as part of these web pages
um also another deployment is all of the
moocs that we've been building
um and uh we've got an increasing number
of courses
um uh both about um
about a variety of kinds of subject
matter whether it's data science or
calculus or whatever else built
using our course authoring platform
which we will eventually make broadly
available but people
can um can can request it even now
um we're we're kind of
trying to build up a sort of a whole
ecosystem around what we're doing
um that includes things like our um
uh our notebook archive our function
repository our data repository i'll
probably talk about those a little bit
more later
um we're also in addition to trying to
build uh software
we're also developing further our
services efforts
so people who say uh i just want to get
something that works
and i want to build it with uh with our
technology
um there's both um our technical
services
to implement something specific and
there's uh wolfram solutions
which is concerned with architecting
sort of a whole solution
and they've been doing a lot of that for
for all sorts of fortune 50 companies
building sort of from the future type
solutions um
using the technology that that we have
they're also those are sort of i
consider these kind of on-ramps
for the use of our technology in a bunch
of different places there are some much
more personal on-ramps
uh things like our summer school there's
some projects from our summer school
this year
uh there's definitely some physics
themed ones there um
or a summer camp for high school
students um also some projects um
uh from from that from this year here
well so um we're also trying to develop
kind of an office hours mechanism
for people uh from the community to
interact um
in in a good way with um with our
internal team and our r d
staff and so on that will be something
that's coming online soon
uh we also for people who are doing
startups and so on we have a new thing
we call our will from eureka program
uh which is kind of a pre-incubator uh
kind of
educational program for people who want
to kind of understand our way
of being able to develop products and
doing innovation and how that turns into
companies
and that's something again we can uh
people can can find out about from us
and in terms of sort of on-ramps and
interaction don't forget our live
streams i've been doing that um
almost every day live streaming kind of
our internal
um design meetings and so on it's a very
uh uh
it's it's um it provides a very sort of
open transparent way
for us to interact with people and get
feedback and so on
uh also mentioned by the way our our um
uh open bug tracking system
which i know quite a few people here
have been making use of
and we will be doing more live streams
related to that soon
all right i guess it is demo time let me
um
i've been been talking about all sorts
of general things let's
let's let's look at some actual uh
what's coming in
in 12.2 so
let me see here let me just save this
someplace where i'm
before i mess that up um and
let me just uh
oops
there we go all right
so okay what's coming in 12.2
well the first the first big area that
um i mentioned earlier is video so
if i have a video see what video this is
that's being read just for that's just a
file name okay this is a video from the
2009
technology conference and uh i i know
some of you have come to
you've been actually conferencing the
video directly and then particularly for
those who
are new here today i thought i would say
so that so that's what a video in a
notebook
looks like just like we can have uh
images in a notebook so now we can also
have videos in a notebook
but now this video thing we can compute
with it so for example i can say
get me 10 frames from that video okay
so now it'll just get me ten frames as
images from that video
okay and that there's some or i could
say something like
let me take that video and let me make a
video
time series map and let me try and
compute
the mean value of the rgb components
okay it's going to take a little while
because videos are big grind growing
grind
and okay let's um let's see what we can
do here let's make
a stateless plot with red green blue
here
and this is now going to show me as a
function of position in that video
um what uh uh what the um
uh what the average colors were in those
images
okay so this is now operating on videos
as we can operate on all sorts of kinds
of things
and if we wanted to for example we could
slice out um
the let's say we could just go down here
and we could slice out
the audio from that video and how long
this will take but
um just take that audio let's see what
happens this is reversing it
anyway that was that was the result of
just taking the audio
as another object from that video and
doing a computation on it
so we can also uh do something like um
i can do all sorts of more elaborate
things let's see i might have another
one here
see if we can do this let's see this is
this is doing a video map
that is let's see whether this can be
done in a reasonable time
oh did something all right let's see
what happens here let's just see we can
now now it'll open that one in a
separate
viewer let's see if we can do this so
what this will do
oh that was boring it was quite boring
what i did there was i
i just blended every five seconds of the
video together
um and uh um
kind of like everything was was ghosted
out there didn't didn't look that
exciting but i could as well
have uh done a video map with some kind
of machine learning thing and done face
recognition on each frame
all those kinds of good things or done
that with the time series map
or i could just take some random
manipulate here let's try this
okay so here we have some some some
random little manipulate that i did made
that's one line long
and now let's see what happens if i just
say make a video
of that manipulate and i probably could
have um
oh let's see that um
this is probably grinding grinding
grinding it might take a long time
because it's actually taking a while to
render each frame but the main point is
that this will now create a regular uh
sort of maximal efficiency video with
all kinds of codecs that you can then
embed on a website or anything else
directly from a manipulate like that
um i think i should uh
not not finish this here let's um
um
okay so let's let's keep going so then
another thing that's new in
in 12.2 and by the way i should explain
that what i'm showing you is obviously
a prototype version of 12.2 so all kinds
of things may go horribly wrong yeah
um this is uh this is just an animated
image
so it's kind of a junior video but it's
not something you can immediately
indirectly include in notebooks and this
is just coming from a png file
an animated png okay well let's talk
about user interface
um let's uh here's something um
here's something interesting that we
decided to add
when you type in math we've got some
lots of wonderful capabilities for
typing in math that means something
to the system but sometimes you just
want to type math that doesn't really
mean anything just like you want to type
text that doesn't have direct
computational meaning
one thing we've now added is the
capability of just typing in tech
for example so if i type in i type
control
dollar and then i type let's say
backslash frac let's see one over
x and then now this is a piece of input
that was just given in tech now this
particular one
was given in an input cell and it in
fact
can be interpreted as a piece of valid
wolfram language input
but we can also just input in a sense
meaningless math and if we're
making you know this is text and now we
start off with a
um a piece of meaningless math here and
let's say i could say
backslash math frack
s-o-n let's try that
okay that wasn't very exciting
i would have expected that to do
something more interesting let's do
something more interesting
let's just put in um here let me see if
i can do um
uh control dollar let me try this i'm
not sure if this is gonna work
okay maybe that will work okay that's a
big lump of tech
see what that does um okay so now that's
then rendered
that tech directly as a piece of sort of
meaningless math
as part of the text that i've got there
so you can see it there
um so this is something i think will be
very convenient for people
who in a sense want to write narrative
math that doesn't yet have computational
meaning
um okay another thing
that uh is again sort of a
straightforward convenience
um is uh auto linking of um
of hyperlinks and actually coming with
that
is some the ability to we have a new
uh hyperlink dialogue which um has all
kinds of
convenient ergonomic features uh
relevant to linking to notebooks as well
as linking to things on the web
um another thing that we have um which i
have to show you in a in a prototype of
the prototype
let's see if i can bring this up here
okay there we go
is um uh is a new capability which
actually is something we've had for a
few years
in uh in documentation and so on it is
the idea of click to copy
so if i say click to copy of something
like i don't know
x to the fifth or something now i have
something that says x to the fifth
i as i hover over it i get a thing that
says copy to clipboard i click it
if i now go here and i paste it it will
have
that in the mouse so to speak so click
to copy is something which is actually
a default for some pieces of published
notebooks in the cloud
it's a default for some of our
documentation but now it's something you
can also have
in any notebook that you produce
okay let's go back to um something a bit
more computational let's let's talk
about a
a different area um let's talk about
some a new thing that we're bringing in
which is spatial statistics
so turns out there's some uh this
idea you know we've got statistics of
things in time like time series and so
on
uh we've also got the idea of spatial
statistics of
of things in space that can be treated
statistically so let's say
this is spatial point date or 100 300
random points
in two dimensions and we can ask things
like what's the mean point density there
okay so it's just some number we can say
what's the point density function
and now we'll get something which is an
actual function um
that is the the the function that
represents the density of these randomly
chosen points
so for example we could say just make me
a 3d plot
of that density function now that's the
density function
of those random 3d point random points
or i could say let's let's compute the
pair correlation function
of those points so now this is computing
uh correlations between all of those
pairs of points if we now say
now let's plot that pair correlation
function as a function of distance
this particular one won't be all that
exciting um it's just
okay it's just showing that the pair
correlation is close to one for these
particular points
but this is now allowing you to
essentially take spatial data
uh positions of things and do
computations with that
and um now uh let's see
we could take um to take another example
we can
this this kind of thing works not only
for abstract points but also for
for uh points in um um
in um i'm surprised that's still blue
okay
but for points in um in actual actual
geographical points okay so what we did
here was we got spatial point data
of some data about u.s national parks
and there
the when we said what's uh make a point
what is this this is some
strange bug oh dear dear dear
okay well that that's um okay
i was showing you um that's what i get
for running a prototype build i thought
this um
okay there we go um
so now if we wanted to we could take um
the whole idea of random processes
applies as well to spatial data as it
does
to standard distributions like a normal
distribution or something
this is now a point process and so now
this is saying
let's get that geographic point process
um and we've we've chosen points now in
in the
over the over the us that are uh
picked according to this particular uh
statistical distribution
of spatial statistical distribution
okay so that's a new thing is spatial
statistics
uh lots of interesting things there um
while we're talking about
uh geo um these uh we have
not only sort of merging geometry
with geography but also merging topology
with geography a kind of geotopology
and so we've got all kinds of issues
like let's say we pick a bunch of points
which can be in lat long space and now
we can do things like say
uh what's a polygon inside a polygon
inside a polygon
uh geographically and yes you know the
country of san marino is important
because it's a hole in italy and so on
but this is a general uh kind of thing
where we can deal with
uh sort of arbitrary topology of con of
of um uh insideness in um
uh in geographic computation
okay another thing in geographic
computation
big thing actually which we've been
working on for quite a few years
is um to make our maps
be made with vector graphics uh so this
is running on a very slow test server
uh real soon now we're running on a
wonderfully fast server but right now
it's running on something really really
slow
so it's going to take it a while to load
this but what we should see here
i hope it's going to load it come now
oh there we go finally okay so what's
important about this
is this is vector graphics and we
computed
every placement of every label here and
as we go in
and i don't know what this stupid bug is
the the um
uh as we go in we can we can zoom in on
this
and we'll find that this is sort of
perfect vector graphics
not um not something that has finite
resolution
um so that's a uh that's an important
piece of technology and actually you'll
see a bunch of things coming out with
maps from us
um that make use of a bunch of
algorithms that we have
for things like label placement and so
on also many different styles of maps
are coming i don't know if i've got one
other example here let's see if we've
got one
more example um this is just a different
style let's see if that
comes up at a better speed um we've got
a variety of
themes for um okay that was just a
different a more web-friendly
version of um of styling for for
for maps but now you can expect kind of
no compromises
uh arbitrarily high-resolution maps uh
from wolverine language
okay um other kinds of things so from
from um uh from space to time
in our theory of physics we've realized
that space and time are a bit more
different than one might have expected
before
but um regardless of that it turns out
that just like there are datums to
represent different coordinate systems
that one can use to label points on the
earth so there are different
kinds of ways to label uh moments in
time
and one thing we've been adding is lots
of new calendars to represent
different kinds of um uh kinds of ways
to represent moments in time and so here
for example if i say
what's now in lots of different
calendars
and we can see uh might take a little
while to compute some of these because
it has to compute
actual astronomical facts um and so here
we have i don't know what some of these
are in japanese calendar
or um the uh the ethiopic
calendar and so on we have all of these
um different essentially datums to
represent time
now available in in the system
well oh and we can do we could do lots
of other kinds of
time computations lots of new time
computations so for example
in the us it's uh you know it's a big
deal it's an election time but a
question you might ask is
when is election day and so here that's
the
algorithmic version of when election day
is and now we can say do a date select
over the years 2020 to 2200
of what uh what day's elections
uh would be held on according to this
formula going up to 2200 and that's
that's now another
another sort of thing we're able to make
computable in the world
um is these kinds of uh computations
about
uh about um dates and so on
all right let's talk about core math
kinds of things
something we've added is a lot of
capabilities for sort of reasoning about
functions
so here's uh function singularities
looking at the singularities of this uh
this function over the complex plane um
we've also uh
uh uh i mean these are these are sort of
properties of functions that end up
being used all over the place
another thing we've done uh is we're
continuing
to add yet more mathematical physics
special functions
this is a la may function which is by
now is a four argument
a very complicated kind of function um
now sometimes
you know when you think oh these are
just obscure special functions
why would one care about them turns out
that
they're important in in all kinds of
places like
here's for example a particular
geoprojection that just got unbelievably
much faster than it was before
because we sped up the evaluation of
jacobi elliptic functions
so okay another core mathematical thing
uh inverse laplace transforms adding
uh bromich contours integra integration
as a
as a way of doing uh many more inverse
laplace transforms we see a result there
that comes out in terms of an
inactivated sum i could say activate
that sum
and then i could say let's uh let's
go ahead and plot that and we see the
various poles uh being in or out of the
contour
as we compute that inverse laplace
transform
okay when talking about math um the um
uh we've also got um uh we've also been
adding to our whole
way of dealing with um uh sort of raw
axiomatic systems this is an axiom for
implicational calculus
um and the idea here is to be able to
to deal at a completely formal level
it's sort of the
more symbolic than just symbolic way of
dealing formally with systems and and we
also have our automated theorem
improving capabilities
which have been progressively expanding
one thing that's happened in the physics
project
is we have become very industrial users
of automated theorem proving in fact for
example
the recent efforts improving equivalence
to categorical quantum mechanics
are really an adventure in automated
theorem proving it's kind of nice thing
to be able to say
yes we actually proved that our model is
equivalent to this and by proved i mean
here's a proof as an actual piece of
computable data
well so oh yeah talking about proofs
um we could talk about sort of the place
where
uh that technology first started to be
used a lot which is in euclid
and euclidean geometry i actually just
wrote this blog post uh
last week i think about um the empirical
if this comes up oh come now
yeah there we go about the empirical
meta-mathematics of euclid
there's kind of a study of uh that's
that's uh an example of fear improving
in our system
but then i was studying kind of the
network of definitions
that um that euclid made in his uh 465
theorems and we're studying kind of the
the graph of dependency this is kind of
a piece of empirical meta mathematics
that i'm interested in doing because i'm
interested in the general theory of
meta-mathematical space
and this is kind of a first example that
we've also looked at i also looked at um
uh all kinds of um uh well i found that
somebody had done
part of what i did 400 years ago don
know that she pointed this out to me
they almost did a little piece of what i
did with uh with dependency graphs for
euclid although they didn't get it quite
right in 1600
um but any case the um uh also looking
at some other
large formalized mathematics uh um data
sets and trying to understand um
uh sort of the the overall structure of
matter mathematical space
but back to euclid um one of the things
that we've done
is to uh add more to our capability for
dealing with
euclid's style geometry so this is a way
of representing
a not just a geometric object but a
geometric construction
um directly in um uh
in wolfram language so this is a way of
making computable
the process of a kind of euclid-style
deduction and so this is kind of an
algebraic version
of that euclid style deduction here's
now an actual instance of the deduction
why is it doing that
well that's what i get for running this
prototype
build why is it not coming up
well it's a dynamic thing come on it
should work
um okay well it should be showing you a
nice picture
of a euclid construction here but for
some reason it is not
um that's unfortunate
okay well we have to say about that
that's going to cause all kinds of
trouble
let me see ah what is it doing
it's gone crazy all right let's see
whether i can get this
to work if i go here and i say
what happens if i say page paste
complete geometric scene i wonder what
that will do
now that didn't do anything um all right
let's try this one more time here
let's try computing this let's try this
again
and let's go back up here and tell it
to
enable dynamic updating let's try one
more time
oh wait a minute something happened
there there we go
who knows what was happening there any
case we can take this euclid
we can take this construction we can
actually interactively move around
the points in this construction there's
another important new thing
is the ability to sort of interactively
drawing draw on the scene
and we can go and go through the
construction here we can go and look at
different steps in the construction
um actually i messed things up here
let's see if i can um
how do i get this maybe i can revert it
here okay so this is that stage in the
construction i can move that b
around a little bit and move it to there
i can move forward in the construction
and um i can eventually get in this case
a quadrilateral triangle constructed
so this is this is kind of making use of
our dynamic interactivity together with
our ability to represent
uh symbolically this kind of um
synthetic geometry
together with under the hood a lot of
very elaborate algebraic computation to
make all this stuff work
okay so let's see moving on from there
um uh let's we're talking about
computational kinds of things
here's a new area where we're kind of
applying computation
and that's in uh biosequences so here
for example if i do this
i will get something which is
essentially a symbolic representation
and what is going wrong
here this is very okay this is kind of a
symbolic representation of a dna
sequence
and so i can do things like i could say
biosequence
translate this and so then it'll take
that dna sequence and translate it to
peptides
isn't that cute um the uh uh
or i could say something like um let's
let's take a biosequence
for this particular gene um and now i'll
i'll go and i'll be looking up that gene
in the human genome
i can get the biosequence for it i could
for example just say
string reverse this um and
then i'll get the reversed sequence or i
could say biosequence complement that
i get the complementary sequence there
and i could then start
doing computations on this so i could
say what's the molecular mass
of that particular um uh piece of of dna
or i could say um i could do something
like this i could say biosequence
translate this uh peptide
um back into those are the those are the
possible dna sequences
that would generate that peptide or i
could say something like
uh let's take the biosequence that comes
from that
that that's a little small piece of dna
let's make an actual molecule out of
that
and of course everything fits together
and we can now say
uh given that molecule let's see if we
can do this let's try and make
uh a 3d plot um a 3d rendering of that
molecule and
now we have that piece of that little
tiny fragment of dna
and now we've got an actual 3d molecule
um that's generated from that
so i i sort of i mean it's kind of a
question of oh isn't it a little bit
crazy to have something like biosequence
translate
as a function in the language well no
it's not because you know what
all users of this language right now are
humans ultimately
although in intermediate stages it's
definitely used by computers
and for us humans we're biological
organisms and uh
biosequence translation is something
that is universally applicable to us
so it's something that makes perfect
sense to have in our
in our computational language to
represent things in the world but it's
kind of really nice to see
how both our string computation
capabilities
um and uh chemical computation
capabilities sort of
uh come together in this kind of
biosequence capabilities area
okay talking of chemistry let me show
you another new thing this is uh
a um let's say let's just draw a
molecule
um okay so this is now a molecular
drawing uh
palette so i can go and i can start some
clicking and i can just start drawing
a molecule i'm not very good at this i
don't really know much about molecules
but anyway let's say i say show
hydrogens
okay i'll show you where the hydrogens
are now i can say return that
okay now i have a molecule i can again
just say
um uh make a molecule plot 3d of that
um and now i can take that molecule that
i just drew and now i can get to
and get this 3d molecular structure um
and i can compute all sorts of things
about the molecule
talking of drawing um here's
another thing after many years we've
built a whole sort of new drawing system
for wolfram language so you can say
canvas and you get up this canvas that
hopefully when i click on it see if this
comes to life
that should give us a an attached cell
here
which contains drawing tools and you'll
see these are very nice new drawing
tools
that allow us to if i know what i'm
doing
what do i do here um oh no that's
what am i doing here uh maybe i need
that
um okay so let's say i start drawing
things
and um i can conveniently select these
things
and um i can make it thicker or whatever
um
the main point is that we have all these
capabilities directly in the language
and in fact we have it set up so that
not only can you
draw from scratch and create something
that is now a computable
drawing you can also take something like
um
take an existing graphic and you can
start annotating that existing graphic
and you could add some region there see
what we add here
um and uh this now becomes an overlay on
one's graphic
um and so if i evaluate this i'll get
something which is an overlay where i
can actually be changing the underlying
graphic it could be a manipulator or
anything else i want
um and this is now a sort of overlay
annotation on it
okay talking about graphics or another
thing i should say is that
this notion of attached cells this thing
down here is an attached cell
we have a new function attached cell
which is an actual user-level way
of manipulating notebook objects to
attach cells to things
okay other graphics kinds of things new
thing uh
radial axis plot otherwise known as a
radar plot or a spider plot or a star
plot
nice in general here another one a
parallel access plot
also having lots of other names this is
something that
just convenient for dealing with highly
multivariate data
um the uh okay another thing we've got
is um arrayplot3d this is a function
i've
long been waiting for so that i'm
running a game of life cellular
automaton
and i'm running it in 3d and you can see
all those little structures that come
out
but this is now array plot 3d is the
thing that's creating this um this
graphic with that
that periodic structure there and so on
and actually this is
to show you something that um this is
just to manipulate
uh with a 3d cellular automaton i i
first made these
pictures of this particular thing with
the cray 1 computer sometime in the
early 1980s
and it's really kind of nice to see that
i can just sort of interactively make
them
by just running a slider now using array
plot 3d
okay so um let's talk about styling of
graphics something that came late in the
12.1
cycle was the idea of cross hatching
it's kind of a thing where if you want
to make
really sort of elegant um uh drawings of
things it's often useful to have these
kind of filling patterns so now we have
that
something we're adding in 12.1 is
different kinds of filling patterns like
this is a
a conic gradient filling that allows us
to
to fill like that um these are these
just other kinds of things of that kind
okay more computational kinds of things
uh
lots of things in machine learning a lot
has been added to our neural net
repository
a lot of new kinds of networks added
here which we can directly use in
welcome language through net model
um the uh we've also
been building a variety of new layers to
to support
the new kinds of things we've been
adding um one new layer is a thing
called functional layer
which provides direct access to kind of
the low-level infrastructure
of neural networks through the mxnet
layer that we have
another thing we've been adding is
compiled layer which allows one to use
the wolfram language compiler
to actually create direct machine code
that can be inserted into a layer
um in um in our neural net framework
another thing we've done
is uh to support um export to the onyx
framework
and that allows one to do things like
build a completely standalone oh wow
what is this that is very odd okay
to build a completely standalone um uh
version
of a neural net that can be for example
the thing i was trying to show you
which came up as a notebook was i
thought going to be a
a cloud document that um uh is an
example
just recently done of taking a neural
net
that was created in more from language
and deploying it directly to the um
machine learning framework on an iphone
so it's something where you can you can
develop in wolfram language and then
deploy
um to uh um to a device like an iphone
as a native piece
of machine learning code i should remind
people that we have a whole variety of
ways in which we can kind of deploy
native code to things
something that just got added in this
version of wolfram language is for our
microcontroller kit
we also can deploy to sort of all
species of arduinos now i think there
are 36 new
kinds of targets where you can take a
piece of
of control systems symbolically
represented functionality in wolfram
language
and compile it down to something that
can be run in a
an independently running microcontroller
in a device for example
completely independent of orphan
language
so okay let's turn to a
oh i should say that also machine
learning
lots of other things being added um
steadily include improving all sorts of
super functions
one that got added is uh face recognize
um
we've also um uh uh
uh so okay so that that's a so so a
thing to say i mean neural nets are a
big sort of framework kind of thing
a kind of one of a series of big
frameworks that have come into almost
numerical computing
over the years first there was linear
algebra now there's neural networks
somewhere in the middle there where
there was optimization
and particularly things like linear
optimization and then convex
optimization
we made a big push to make to provide
kind of industrial strength
convex optimization in wolfram language
we've extended that in version
12.2 to add complex variables and
parametric convex optimization
we also added the capability to connect
to other external optimization libraries
from directly from wolfram language well
now something else that we've been
building towards for about a decade
is some real world pdes
so we've had the capability to do
numerical pde solving
and we built finite element methods and
so on um
but this is kind of a way of
constructing sort of
uh physical models with pdes easily so
this is kind of a
a construction uh element a laplacian
pde
term and there are all sorts of
different pde terms and so on but here
for example we're saying let's do the
eigenvalues let's find the eigenvalues
of a laplacian pde term over a regular
polygon that happens to be a pentagon
and so now if i can say let's make a
list plot of those this is going to show
us
the eigenmodes of a pentagon
and that's showing us probably we can
figure out the symmetries of a pentagon
from looking at the degeneracies of
those eigen modes
so um uh let's see what we can do here
let's see if we take this
let's do something more ambitious let's
say we have a geometry
represented by that region there and now
let's say we want to actually do a let's
say that's a muffler
and let's say we want to actually do a
physical computation about something to
do with that muffler
okay well let's use our knowledge of
actual physical things that's fine using
thermodynamic data which we actually
just extended
in this version to include more with
humidity and other kinds of things about
about air and so on
um but uh we can we can just compute
um the uh these these things about the
real world
now we can define these variables um to
represent
the actual sort of physics of our
muffler and now let's say
we actually set things up with acoustic
pde components and acoustic absorbing
values
those are part of our sort of library of
um building blocks
for sort of physically oriented pdes and
now for example we can do a parametric
solution
to that pde um in the
uh with the region being that muffler
and now we could even go ahead and make
a slice contour plot 3d
of um the uh of that particular solution
at some particular frequency
um in um uh in that system or maybe we
can go on and what's this
we could go on and compute uh the sort
of uh frequency response
of the muffler by actually solving the
pde
that solving the helmholtz equation with
these boundary conditions
and it's just going through and
computing that might take a little while
here
it's um it's computing the result there
and it's going to give us a frequency
response curve hopefully at the end of
this
so uh it's something we've been building
up to for a long time it involves a lot
of computational geometry
a lot of linear algebra a lot of other
kinds of things
uh to be able to to solve sort of real
world pdes in that kind of way
okay let me turn to a different thing
let's talk about programming we've
talked about sort of industrial strength
applied mathematics
let's talk about industrial strength
programming so one question is how do
you make code more
robust so a big thing in this version is
a framework we call the can
confirm and close framework so the issue
is you've got a piece of code
and somewhere in that code something
goes wrong
and what do you do about it how do you
propagate that error
well this is a kind of a symbolic way to
propagate the errors so we say
f of x confirm of y z okay why there's
nothing wrong with y
so the enclosed that catches that
confirm just says oh there's nothing
wrong with that it's just
f of x y z but let's say that y was
actually dollar failed
now that confirm will fail
and it will propagate that confirmation
failure out to the enclosing enclose
and that will now return a failure
object so let's say you're writing a
function called add two
you could say let's write an enclosed
inside my add to function
and now if i say you know add to a four
great
no problem it's going to give six if i
say add to a missing that's one of the
things that confirmed by default
triggers on
it'll just give a failure object so this
is a way of of sort of if something goes
wrong
controlling the sort of the the spread
of errors so to speak and as soon as the
confirm
fails as soon as it fails to confirm it
will immediately
go out to the nearest and closing and
close
so there's a whole family of these
functions um so for example another one
is
is confirmed by and so this says can you
confirm
that by this by this function number q
that this is a number okay great
can you confirm that x is number q no so
that's now a failure object
and similarly here we can say let's
write something like this
which asks to confirm that the thing we
gave first as a string okay great
let's do this oops that's not a string
so make it a failure object
and now we can say let's let's now look
here at confirming
this world thing we now confirm the
world
the this world function now we can map
it over that and it's going to work just
fine
now let's say we do this we map it over
this
and now we've got a an individual
confirmed there
that and that confirm will eventually
fail and that will propagate to the
outer enclosed
and so the whole thing will become a
failure okay so this is an important
thing for making
for taking uh code that you write and
making sure if something goes wrong
if it didn't end up being the thing you
thought it was going to be
propagate that error outwards without
having to write a lot of complicated
code
that checks for the error all the time
if this if this of this
there's a family of these functions
confirmed by confirms by function
confirm match confirms that the thing
you get matches a pattern
confirm quiet confirm that the thing is
quiet and generate a message
confirm assert just check that this
particular assertion is true and so on
the actual design of confirming clone is
quite interesting kind of under the hood
it's a combination lexically dynamically
scoped thing
um which is probably going to be a model
for other things that we do going
forward
another thing that's practical thing uh
in this version is a thing called with
cleanup which is a way of ensuring that
certain cleanup code gets
let's run even when there's an abort
even when a confirm makes you jump out
of something
this cleanup can still happen and so on
for um debugging we're adding some
things in
in version 12.2 if we just have this
table
okay great we can say let's let's put in
here
let's say we want to know how long do
these things take so let's put in just
echo timing here um and i can say
i could say that and now this is going
to tell me how long each of those took
or i could say put in an echo evaluation
here
um there we go and now it will show me
uh what the input and output for the
evaluation was and how long it took
so these are just convenient things to
be able to insert in your code just like
echo you can insert anywhere it still
returns the usual value but it produces
some
sort of side effect showing you what's
going on
okay on the subject of making code
beautiful uh one of the things when
one often writes function pure functions
in wolfram language
and i've for quite a few years often
like using escape fn escape
to write a function like that um one
thing we're adding i'm afraid i don't
think it's working yet
in this version is that you can just
type vertical bar
dash greater than and you will get one
of those some
function objects that
just like if you type dash greater than
you'll get a nice rule symbol
there's just a convenient way to write
function in world from language and a
sort of elegant thing here
okay so another another sort of
programming convenience
um a function called apply to so let's
say i have an image here
now i could say let's say i want to
color negate that image
i can say apply to that image so i say
image at equals color negate
now the image will be uh equal to the
color negation of the image
okay there are also another number of
other new functions like fold wild which
is joining the nest while take wild
family
another thing that's coming people may
know that it's about to be the centenary
of combinators
uh sort of the first actual concrete
instance of the universal computation
uh first sort of uh announced in
december of 1920
um as kind of a part of the the sort of
celebration of the centenary of
combinators
we're making sure that we can support
combinators well in 12.2
combinators as in much early
mathematical logic
involved writing down function
compositions with left associative
function composition
normally our function composition that
we write with an at sign
is right associative it goes like that
but left associative function
application
was a thing back in the day and is
something that is important for dealing
with combinators
so we're introducing this thing called
application which is a left associative
function application
uh as as part of the the combinator
celebration
okay another completely different kind
of thing let's talk about arrays
an array gymnastics so this is something
where we're saying
uh let's reduce an array along a
particular axis
and so this for example is reducing this
array
along its row axis this is reducing the
array along its column axis
and that's a very convenient thing to be
able to do we're saying essentially here
take a mean
of the columns of this in this array and
this is a general function array reduce
it has many
many capabilities for doing these kinds
of things
okay so another thing that talking about
code and so on
we're working on a big project and code
assistant tools
i mean think about kind of semantic
checking you know we've got spell
checking we've got it
same-sex coloring and so on this is kind
of semantic checking of code
using machine learning and using rules
and so on i think it's going to be
something very helpful in terms of
quickly being able to write correct code
one small piece of that that will be in
12.2
is something to do with code formatting
um let me show you that
so here we're going to take um let me
open
a new wl file
so i say new uh
package script.wl so this is a new
um it's going to be a new open language
code file and now let me paste a big
lump of code in here let's see if i've
got this
there we go there's a big lump of code i
pasted it okay
there's a new button at the top here
that says format
cell so i picked this cell so i can now
say format
cell and now it'll run an automatic code
formatter on here
with with certain with a certain set of
choices about how to format this code
now if we pull up a palette we've got
here a code formatting palette
this code formatting palette has a
variety of options for how to format the
code
so there's a notion of what we call
airiness which is how
how airy is this code how um
how how much does it make use of how how
much does it spread out across lines
let me see if i if i set this to full
airiness what's it gonna do
oh there we go so now it's now it's made
this code very very spread out across
lines
if i reduce the airiness level uh over
here
we'll see something where we're where
the code is much more crunched together
on different lines
and so one of the things we're doing is
is to provide these various kinds of
settings
to conveniently format code in different
kinds of ways
um so that's something coming first to
the wolfram language
uh code editor here and we'll also be
able to insert
this kind of capability inside our
external ides we've got a whole
program of being able to take wolfram
language
syntax coloring and so on and making it
available
inside all possible external ides
okay another thing that's coming another
big thing that's coming
is a thing called form notebooks okay
so let's say you want people to enter
some input
maybe it's you want them to uh to fill
out some form okay you can do that
by just having um by just having
something that you create with form
function and so on
but let's say that you want something
much more elaborate that has all kinds
of notebook capabilities
but you want people to sort of be able
to fill it out as a form
well then you can use this new kind of
construct that we call a form notebook
and a form notebook is a notebook that
is a notebook that you can treat as a
form
so let me try to show you how this works
it's a little bit uh
complicated to understand everything
that's going on here so we
say insert here and we can say insert
uh a form element here let's say we
insert radio buttons here
so this is now inserting a piece of code
that represents radio buttons so there
are the radio buttons that we're going
to represent here
let me go ahead and insert something
else here let me say let's insert
a let's say a slider here
okay so that's the code version of it
that's the um
and let's say we put something up at the
top here we say heading here
and we say you know
enter the right value
okay so now we have a an authoring
form notebook now let's say and we could
also let's just for fun let's put an
editable notebook area down here as well
okay so now let's say let's generate
from that so what do we want to generate
we can generate various things but let's
just say
uh let's see let's just say we want to
oh yeah here that's right we want to we
want to create
a form notebook and then the form
notebook is going to do something with
that form we'll just say create document
okay
so this is now a built form notebook
okay
so all those things those controls that
we put in this is now the version so
let's imagine
that you were generating a sort of a
quiz for some education application
you would author it in the form
authoring notebook you would generate it
as a form notebook
and then somebody might fill in values
here so let's say we fill in
you know something like this okay then
we got a result okay
now we say given this form notebook
let's
submit this form notebook and that pull
down that i was kind of ignoring before
is telling us what should you do when
you submit that form notebook
should you send the results to an api
should you put it to a data bin
what should you do here all i'm going to
do is i'm going to just create
another document from it so i run that
form notebook
and what i've generated here is an
association
and that association is the set of
results
that i got from this so it says key one
that was the default name
of this element of the form notebook
just has label b
and this one had a particular value for
the for the um
uh for the slider and so on and this is
now the notebook piece
and so on so this is now this is what i
entered in that form
and this could have gone into a program
to interpret and i could have got
something which just said
okay i'll do some assessment of this and
i'll tell me whether i got the right
answer
whatever else so this is a mechanism for
authoring a form notebook
you deploy the form notebook anybody all
kinds of people can fill out this form
notebook
the results of what they fill out can be
sent back in a variety of ways
for a program to then do computations on
it
so one thing that's coming that um is
related to this that you can see how
this might fit in
is a function called assessment function
assessment function is a thing that
takes
inputs there's an assessment function
object it takes
inputs and it tries to figure out
to assess those inputs okay so in this
case dog was a correct answer cat was a
incorrect answer there's the assessment
assessment result object
now this gets a lot more elaborate
because the assessment function
can be saying move a locator around on a
map
and see whether you get inside a country
border or not or put in this algebraic
expression and see whether these kinds
of transformations
uh can take it to some other form or not
so it's a it's a way of
it's kind of a little bit like
interpreter but it's a way of
of generally assessing inputs and it's
something that will be used a lot i
think in connection with form notebooks
for example for education applications
okay so we will also be building out a
whole sort of courseware repository
in which people can create things using
form notebooks
using our course authoring tools can
make things
that are basically just like the mooc
that was made from my elementary
introduction to wolven language
but all the tools will exist to just
directly make something like this
in a very convenient way
well something else let's let's change
topics a bit
something that's always happening with
as we move forward with our
computational language
is kind of the growth of our knowledge
base and um
the uh particularly given some new
partners that we have
we've been kind of uh really really
driving that knowledge base
in a whole variety of directions so
let's take a random example let's take
food
we now support five hundred thousand
kinds of foods
and um they're about twenty or thirty
thousand in a typical grocery store
so for example let's say we have a
kitkat i rather like those
there's a kitkat and now we could say
you know let's generate the nutrition
label from a kitkat
based on our knowledge base there's the
result
um so you know lots of different things
here's one that isn't really
my particular kind of thing this is a
let's take 10 random weight training
exercises
okay let's take one particular one i
barely know what this is i'm sorry to
say
um let's take what do we know about a
front raised weight training exercise
okay
we could say let's um uh let's find out
what are the muscles that are used in
that now of course
everything is now computable so all
these different muscles and so on
these are all computable things so we
could for example take them into anatomy
data
anatomy plot 3d and we could just plot
where are those muscles um showing also
a skeleton to attach them to here
um oh it's got to got to load in all
kinds of geometric data about um about
anatomy here
but eventually we should get some um
we should get um a result by the way one
thing we've been doing a lot
is um optimizing the caching of things
that have to be
the the bucketing and caching of things
that have to be loaded from the cloud
for our knowledge base
so you'll see a lot of things this one
we haven't gotten to yet but a lot of
things um
uh we're just much much faster um in
terms of the way that large-scale pieces
of our knowledge base can be loaded into
for example a desktop or from language
um
okay as it grinds away here let me see
well i'm i'm just there's lots of other
pieces of the knowledge base why is this
so slow i don't know what's going on
here
um who knows um
i was going to show you um uh all sorts
of weird things i
i had a note here about cultivars of
tomatoes
um just one of the things that we're now
into in kind of the structure of our
knowledge
base by the way another thing that
happens in knowledge base
that's really disappointing let me let
me kill that i know what
that is very weird okay
this is um that's what i get for as i
say
showing you the very latest 12.2 okay
that's
something went horribly wrong there
let's quit that
and quit it and let's just let's just
see
whether if i were to um
run this again it might work better i
don't know
um okay in any case
um there's there's a lot of things now
oh what a silly thing to do why why
around it again if it didn't work once
maybe it won't work again
um the uh
so
let's see um a lot of things that we
might think of as data
but they're actually very computable
data so for example here's an example
this is geometric scenes geometric
scenes are another kind of thing in the
knowledge base
but now there is a geometric scene which
is euclid book 5 proposition 19.
here it is as a symbolically represented
scene
which we can then say let's get a random
instance of that scene so we
we're using kind of a knowledge base to
get something which is now computable
and this seems to be a construction of
some kind and i'm sure we can compute
things with it
um
another thing we can do another new
thing is
with the demonstrations project we can
actually
our all of our 13 000 demonstrations
including many contributed by people who
are probably here
um are now available as computable
objects in welcome language
and so for example we could take one of
those demonstrations and we could say
give us the manipulate that comes from
that demonstration
and there it is directly there as a as a
cell in our notebook and we can do we
can do all kinds of computations with it
so uh that's that's another
example of um um
of a way that uh the knowledge base has
more computable kinds of things and i
might mention the whole
notebook archive which we're slowly
building out where one can store all
these computational essays
that contain uh these kinds of things
okay different topic let's talk about
more about kind of the outside world now
not in terms of computable data
but in terms of importing things big
thing being added in version 12.2 is the
import of pdf
so this is now importing from a raw pdf
file
this is now importing into computable
data the first
page of a fine paper here um
about um uh which we can now do
computations on
and in fact for example that that
picture i showed you earlier
of the big word cloud of of papers um
that
uh sight wolf language um is
uh was was got by just using importing a
pdf
from preprint servers
okay so um another thing about the
outside world
wiki data data uh you know wikidata is
unbelievably much messier
than the kind of curated knowledge base
that we have
um but it's still convenient to be able
to kind of poke at it and get things
this is now
doing a geo lookup against wikidata
um okay in terms of things about the
outside world
uh talking about kind of infrastructure
of the outside world is a very practical
thing
uh this is import of pem files
permissions files um this is being able
to
import things like security certificates
um that's a a new kind of symbolic
object in our system is a security
certificate
of the kind that websites can issue and
so on and the importance of this is it
kind of allows you to flow through
uh kind of the infrastructure of the
world so to speak
uh carrying various kinds of
authentications and permissions and so
on
we introduced some system credentials
keychain related things
in previous version now we're
introducing uh system credentials uh
now we're introducing um uh the um
um uh the the um
uh the capability to um um to do
um uh to deal with security certificates
um we also i mentioned our blockchain
capabilities we've been steadily adding
blockchain capabilities here's an
example
blockchain we just added in the last
couple of weeks bloxburg
this is the most recent block mined on
the bloxburg blockchain
um that's uh so that's another kind of
thing
um by the way as a practical matter
version 12.1 and 12.2
are compatible with the upcoming version
11.0 of the mac os
mac operating system otherwise known as
big sur earlier versions are not
compatible with that
unfortunately unlike wolfram language
which has remained compatible for
34 years the same cannot be said of of
computer operating systems
we're not able to predict the future
with respect to computer operating
systems so
before big sur existed we couldn't make
things compatible with big sur
and that means only 12.1 and 12.2 are
compatible with it
um i mentioned uh okay so here's another
practical thing this is about remote
evaluate
so remote evaluate allows one to
remotely evaluate
wolfram language code um on a remote
computer so this is running on my
desktop computer
and it's telling me that i have 68
gigabytes of memory available
on that desktop computer i i was
thinking i could run current
image on my desktop computer but that
doesn't seem to work for some reason
probably a permissions issue um but any
case you can imagine
uh just running remote evaluate mapping
it across a whole network of raspberry
pi's that are making
various kinds of measurements and so on
this is a convenient way to do sort of
remote computation
okay another long-awaited capability
is being able to do uh remote
computation
remote batch computation in the cloud
so for example if you're going to use
aws if you're going to use amazon
to do to run a bunch of big jobs
there is now a mechanism for using
remote batch
submit to submit jobs
to your amazon account and so here we've
got this is probably some big messy
thing
about uh this is comes amazon
credentials
um that um uh is um these are these are
set up by um uh by another function
but now we can go ahead and say let's
submit
this job now into the amazon
infrastructure to run
as a batch job and um this is going to
be
running what is this doing this is a map
job
that's mapping across a bunch of a bunch
of different things
it's submitting that job and we should
now once the once the job submission
comes back
uh remember this is a batch job so we're
not in control of how long it takes
we can say once that batch submission
goes through we should be able to say
uh this is we're waiting for the for the
amazon system
to accept our batch job um we should be
able to say
show us a dynamic status visualization
of the state of our batch job
and i don't know how long it probably
depends on how busy how busy aws is
right now how long it will take that
batch job to submit
um but we can go ahead and um uh
well it's taking an awfully long time uh
i maybe i may be timing out here
um uh in any case eventually
it will submit the batch job to the
amazon infrastructure we'll get back a
task object
we'll be able to see um how the job is
running and eventually we'll find out
the job is finished
okay there we go there's the remote
batch object that represents our job
we can now say show us the dynamic
status visualization
this is saying there are 16 cores that
we allocated here
16 places where it's runnable if we wait
long enough
we will get evaluation results right now
if we ask for evaluation results i
suspect
we'll get a big pile of missings um okay
requesting child dog job metadata from
provider
so this is this is now querying amazon
to ask the status of our job
and ask whether the results have come
back from these different parts of the
job
very boring they're all missing not
available if we wait for a few more
minutes and run this again
uh we'll probably find that the job has
been run and the results come back
okay but anyway that's a that's a
practical capability
uh for running large-scale computations
including machine learning and so on um
to uh within um uh
fro with wolfram language and there's
there's a lot of moving parts that have
to work to have this whole pipeline
operate
and it does very nicely um we're
supporting right now amazon will be
supporting azure in the future
we're also supporting charity engine um
which is a uh a kind of a a public
crowd-sourced computing platform um uh
for doing large-scale computation
okay from talking that's a very
practical kind of computation
let's also talk about another kind of
computation let's talk about quantum
computing
um our package for quantum computing um
is is coming in this version um we've
got
uh uh we can do uh all sorts of things
it's a little bit reminiscent of um
uh of a neural net package because of
the neural net subsystem
because it it it allows one to take
these sort of blocks of computation and
put them together
now i mean and we can go ahead and do
computations here and we can say
let's actually run the thing and um okay
this is a
quantum tensor product of quantum
discrete states
et cetera et cetera et cetera and we can
actually run it and we can compute
uh some results here of um of actual uh
probabilities for different outcomes and
so on
now i mean this is all well and good
this is a simulator of quantum computing
it's a whole different issue whether you
can actually run this on a real quantum
computer
one of the things that's really
interesting about this is you can take
our representation of quantum computing
and there's now even a function
in the function repository that will
simply compile
this representation of quantum computing
into multi-way systems
in other words you can compile this
representation of quantum computing
into our model of physics so in a sense
that's kind of if you want to know if
the model really makes sense this is a
kind of proof by compilation
you can take the representation of
ordinary quantum mechanics and compile
it into our model
and this is kind of the demonstration
that that's possible um
but uh it's also an interesting thing
for just exploring quantum computing
although
i think multi-wave systems will actually
in our and our models
actually provide a yet more powerful way
to think about how
about quantum computing and also show
some of its limitations
okay um
let's see we talked a little bit about
cloud deployment
um let's uh
all sorts of things have become a bit
more streamlined with cloud deployment
you know
the way it works on the sort of inside
story of this we have versions of world
from language like version 12.1 version
12.2 and so on
the cloud is continually being updated
so we just pushed
version 1.56. of the cloud
and there's a bunch of things coming in
1.57
which will be coming quite soon um and
so the cloud is continually getting
upgraded
um even between different versions of
language it's also true
that we have paclets that are being
filled up late updated
in world from language as well as of
course the knowledge base is being
updated
and these are all things that um uh that
that can happen
um okay so
uh something that i think will be
important i was going to mention
something else here
about the compiler the compiler is a big
project it's slowly coming along big
thing that's happening that won't be
quite in 12.2
is a lot of but it will be in a packet
update actually there's a lot of
new tooling for using the compiler with
dynamic libraries
and being able to compile a piece of
code and have it be
able to be put in a function that's in
the function repository
and have when that function in the
function repository is downloaded you
get the correct piece of compiled code
for whatever platform
your computer is is uh is using and so
on uh also with
more data structures now and all kinds
of other things okay something important
for developers
is the paclet system uh and paclet tools
so in version 12.1 we kind of
mainstreamed the whole paclet system
paclet system is what allows um
us to um uh
um is what allows us to deploy
a complex thing within a wolfram
language environment
and by a complex thing i mean not just
functions but also
things like palettes and documentation
and all sorts of other kinds of things
that you can plug into the system and by
the way
something that's really coming is just
an awful lot of other things you can
plug in
whether it's your own version of a
random number generator your own format
that you're importing
your own um uh service connection all
kinds of different things
so so that's something that's that's
coming there now
um one thing uh when you build packlets
okay let me just start this up here um
when you build packlets there's now in
version 12.2
there's an elaborate system
and why is this not working this should
be coming up somewhere did it come up
somewhere but i'm not even seeing it
oh yes it did there it is it's hidden um
so this is the beginning of something
which will get further developed
this is the beginning of being able to
write documentation just like the
documentation that we write
for the the orphan language write your
own documentation
and now i can say okay let me just have
a function name
test function let's say here and now
this
is um and now this will bring up i hope
a function page this is just like the
function pages that we
uh that we create for documenting a
language
you can fill in all these things and
this is kind of going to be deployed as
a form notebook
and once you fill all these things in
you can then build it
into documentation that can show up on
the web or in product
um on the desktop uh for for the paclet
you've created so this is a way to kind
of create
um uh something which has the same kind
of richness of documentation structure
and so on
as as anything that you could that we've
been able to create
uh directly in in the in the main system
so that's the thing that you can then
take all that documentation
and put it in your packet and deploy
your packet to the paclet server
uh coming soon will be a public packet
repository but you can also privately
deploy packets
um to a paclet server
okay so for example another thing that's
coming is um
the ability to make a new uh
just just immediately to make a new
where is this
oh yes new function page new guide page
okay here we go
this is just if you just want to make a
disembodied guide page a disembodied
page
that just is your favorite collection of
functions that you want to use
um this is a way to do that and this
this provides you a variety of
a built-in services and will also allow
you to deploy this
so that it becomes a um a cloud page
that you can then just have as something
that you have as a favorite in your web
browser or something like that
um or something where you can just use
this
as a guide page to provide you
convenient functions so for example we
have one of these i showed earlier
for our physics project just a big list
of the functions that we use in the
physics project
and that's where i always go when i'm
actually using one of those functions to
go find the function that i can
can use so
a thing that um uh thing that we've
really been developing over the last
year
is the function repository so the
function repository is a way of just
adding functionality
very conveniently to wolfram language
and
the function repository uh roughly more
than doubled the the number of functions
in it since last year it now has
1651 functions in it as of today i think
these functions are all things that
go through a curation process a review
process
um but they're written by by the
community
and they're just all kinds of different
functions here and
i don't know let's pick a random example
and a sky position chart
here it is and what's really important
about this is i can just click here
i can go to my notebook um you know i
can just go to my um um
my notebook anywhere and i can just say
wherever my notebook was
let's see where was it let me pick the
right one here
um you know i go to my notebook here and
i just paste that in
and now it's a resource function and
oh great this is very sick in some way
ah okay this is what i get
again this is a um you know what i am
going to
this is probably some interaction with
those packlet tools that i just showed
you so let me quit this
and start it again and uh
you see this is this is uh is always one
of the interesting things with these
keynotes these are very um
uh real life kinds of things okay so
here
here we've got this resource function
that i just copied from that page and so
what should happen if all is working
correctly
is that we should see why it's it's
doing this but
um we should just see that it loads in
that function
uh oh wow how weird
very weird okay well let's try another
one let's
try um
let's try something to do with um here's
a covert 19 epidemic data
okay let's try this let's try let's try
pasting that in here
okay so let's now just see that works it
says finding resource
and now it should if it's not horribly
broken um
okay there we go so now it's it's just
running that function
and what's convenient is that function
i the the function repository just had
to give the definition of that function
it was leveraging everything we built in
waltham language to be able to know
oh there's these entities which are
countries there's all this uh
structure of associations and so on and
so on and so on
um there are all these things that we're
able to take where
um uh where it's um
um uh where where where we're sort of
leveraging
the um um
all the capabilities what's this let's
see how that wasn't what i needed
let's look at what this actually is okay
oh boy
this is a very complicated um there's a
very complicated set of things that one
has to go through here to get them
to get this example by the way this is
using click to copy it's very convenient
to get examples from here but we could
pick a a random entry from the function
repository i can even do that
programmatically
and the whole point is that the function
repository what makes the function
repository makes sense
is that you've got all the welcome
language to build on
typically when people build libraries
for low-level programming languages and
so on
you know you'll have a library that's
you know for doing some particular kind
of image processing
you look at the library it's got 300
functions in it and
you know 295 of those functions are
support functions that deal with the
processing of images in this way or that
way
and only five of them are really the the
you know
the the the the killer functions that
are actually doing the interesting
unique thing but you had to build all
that support because you didn't have
this kind of whole computational
language to provide a representation of
all these kinds of things
computationally
and more from language we have that and
so when we build a function repository
function
we can just add that one little piece of
functionality for the one thing we want
building on top of that existing
computational language and i think
that's a very powerful combination and
by the way
you know you can take those things
written in some low-level language let's
say a python
program or something you just take any
one of those python libraries
and you can just wrap it as a function
repository entry
and and that's something that it's a
non-trivial piece of software
engineering that we can get that you
know they're different versions of
python
they're not compatible they're weird
library things that happen we're
dependency tracking and so on
i think we're slowly getting all of that
sorted out so that you'll be able to
just say
here's this thing it happens to be
implemented using this external python
library
but you can wrap it in a function
repository entry and you can just run it
just like i ran any of these other
things
and the fact that it calls this external
code is is not relevant it's still
running
using all of the capabilities of our
computational language
i should say by the way that i think as
we build out the the paclit repository
um paclets are things where you can
create a whole new world in a backlit
you can change everything about the
interface to your wolfram language
you can change all these functions um
but it's
you know you're kind of when people use
that paclet they're diving into this
whole world
you can also have just a single function
repository entry where people just using
this particular function in the usual
world of the world from language
um i think the sort of a combination
that we're starting to use
which is there is a paclet that contains
a lot of complicated stuff
but it sticks its head out so to speak
through these
a few particular functions in the
function repository and so
really the way that people have to think
about this backlight they don't have to
think about the whole big structure
they just have to think i want to use
this particular function great i can use
it in this way
okay well so and by the way
when um i should say that um uh you can
do things like put paclets and github
you can create github repositories
it's a good thing to do it's great for
will be nice to see more github
repositories based on welfare language
makes us look bad
when when people are not bothering to
put things in github because they just
need to write a few lines of code
but it's still useful to put it there
because it helps people to see what's
possible with wolfram language and so on
um by the way in uh already in version
12.1 i think at the late stages of
version 12.1
we made it a lot easier to enter data in
the data repository to get data at the
point where
it is computable enough that you can
just read it directly and dwarven
language
that's a really good thing to do if
you're trying to publish data that
you're creating
by the way the function repository is
also a good place to publish
things that results you know now that we
have this whole ecosystem of citing
functions
it's like publish your your results as a
function in the function repository
it then becomes a thing that can be used
as part of the process
of creating research papers and and so
on
um i think that um it's uh
in general publishing notebooks to the
cloud um
is something that's just a really great
way to publish things and particularly
when it comes to kind of computational
essays that mix
sort of narrative text together with
computational language
well i've gone on way too i haven't gone
on
as long as i did last time we have we
had more functions to talk about
but i have uh managed to get through
them more quickly than i did last time
um i think maybe i should uh so i've
tried to give you some sketch
of what's coming in 12.2 it's a longer
story what's coming in the longer term
there's lots more things coming um lots
more things that we've been developing
things we've been developing for a
decade that are
slowly moving towards fruition um i
think the um
the thing that um uh that i should say
to uh to kind of try and um close this
off
is you know we've been working very hard
we've been working very hard for the
last 34 years actually
to develop this whole capability
of this computational language that we
have um
i think that it's gotten a long way it's
kind of an interesting process that the
further we get
the further we can see about where we
could get to
and uh that means we've been seeing kind
of this accelerating trend
of the kinds of things that we can sort
of make computational
and it's it's allowed us to kind of have
this um
uh this this uh we've been gradually
sort of making more and more of the
world computational and i think we've
got a really long way in doing that
um although from where we are now i can
see even more things to do that with
the challenge now is to have the world
really be able to take advantage
of what we've done and really take
advantage of this kind of computational
paradigm
as i say many of you are sort of uh
people who are bringing artifacts from
the future into the present day
and making use of these capabilities
it's kind of a neat thing to do it's
sort of a superpower
you can bring in to apply to different
kinds of things i think we sort of have
a responsibility
to to try and deliver this message to a
broader
uh a broader range of people in the
world in a broader range of
organizations
we're doing our best to try to make that
happen in terms of making sort of our
computational intelligence
available in the most effective ways
through the most effective challenge
channels with the most effective
partners and so on but it's something
that
uh there's just there's just a huge
amount to do there it's something that
is kind of an exciting thing because
we're at this kind of watershed moment
in intellectual history
where this kind of computational
paradigm that is kind of a
a great new thing it's it's you know
maybe the last such paradigm
was perhaps the mathematical paradigm
which is maybe 400 years
uh since it sort of became uh
streamlined we've now got such a
paradigm
it's a it's kind of a terrific time to
be around and doing things
and i think we now have as i say
something which perhaps in some ways
is a is a kind of is a thing brought in
from the future
um but brought to today and something
that um
uh we can all make use of and it's uh
it's something where i would like to
would like to encourage people to do
what we're trying to do but we're just a
small company really focused on
on trying to grow plant the seed of
technological capability
to really deliver what's needed to to
actually make this sort of computational
paradigm to take take root
and to really make it to the point where
sort of one can rely on computational
intelligence everywhere
and where people understand
computational language as they today
understand things like mathematical
notation
and where people can use that
computational language as a way to
to uh provide sort of a foundation for
sort of computational
x for all x and i think there's just a
an awful lot of wonderful things that
can happen
as sort of all these things all these
x's
become computational x's and as we can
bring sort of the clarity of thinking
and uh that computational x brings to
all these different fields and by the
way also
allows one to bring in a lot of other
people who might not otherwise have been
able to access
those kinds of fields with this kind of
computational way of thinking about
things
it's just much broadens out the kind of
kind of people who can contribute to
what's going on
because in a sense you're sharing the
burden with your computer by
by expressing things computationally you
immediately have a collaborator your
computer
to do things um and that's something
that uh
we sort of increasingly see i mean i've
seen that for example in our physics
project
that something as well as great human
collaborators it's really critical to
have that uh
computational collaborator to really do
things which which i think otherwise
uh would not have been possible and uh
would not have happened for a very long
time
all right well i should should wrap up
there thank you very much and welcome to
uh
the conference i know there's lots of um
lots of interesting talks that are going
to happen
and lots of get togethers which i look
forward to attending
um i'll be doing a sort of q a session i
think it's tomorrow
um about uh whatever people want to ask
about
um and uh i would say that the things
i've talked about about sort of the the
near-term future of 12.2
i think most of those things will be
covered by by particular talks and
people can uh
are welcome to ask about them um and uh
uh look forward to interacting with
people over the next few days
all right thanks very much